Ich glaube ich habe dich die letzten paar Wochen schon immer hier pünktlich um neun im Chat gesehen, und das schon bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe.
So, ist dann die Lautstärke richtig?
Ja.
Wow, Teams haben die Lautstärke richtig?
Okay.
Dann die Lautstärke richtig?
Ja.
Wow, Teams hat nichts an der Lautstärke rumgestellt.
Nice.
Habe nicht gedacht, dass das geht.
Teams muss da aus Prinzip immer was dran rumstellen.
Moin, Battlecheap.
Oh, gibt es eigentlich einen Browser Plugin, was das hier ausblendet, was quasi den Browser
Fullscreen macht, ohne in Fullscreen zu machen, also quasi das hier ausblendet, weil Fullscreen
an sich ist doof, da sieht man hier unten nichts mehr.
Ich will aber eigentlich nur dieses Fenster aufhaben ohne Leiste und den Rand.
Geht das?
Bestimmt.
Da gibt es bestimmt irgendwas, im Zweifelsfall geht das sogar ohne Plugin, dass man irgendwas
an den Browser-Settings macht.
Kiosk Mode, wie macht man den an?
Nee, Kiosk Mode ist wahrscheinlich dann Fullscreen, oder?
Wie gesagt, das bringt ja nichts.
Naja, ist auch egal, so wichtig ist es nicht.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Oder als PWA, da müsste man den Twitch-Chat als PWA machen, das ist tatsächlich eine
gute Idee.
Dass man irgendwie sagt, irgendwie öffne als extra App, ich weiß was du meinst, jaja,
das wäre wahrscheinlich echt nicht verkehren, wobei dann FFZ und so nicht funktioniert.
Man kann einfach den Rahmen um den Browser wegbekommen, muss doch gehen.
Geht ja offensichtlich im Fullscreen, jetzt bräuchte man nur Fullscreen ohne Fullscreen
zu sein.
Aber so immer, ist ja nicht so wichtig, würden da ein paar Zeilen mehr auf den Bildschirm
passen.
Moin, Unik, HTML-Edit und randlöschen, das geht ja schlecht, das hier ist ja nicht Teil
von der Seite, das ist ja Teil vom Browser.
Wie geht's, ja ganz gut, ich bin müde, obwohl ich schon fast, fast eineinhalb Stunden wach
bin.
Aber ich hab nix gemacht, also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das schon eineinhalb Stunden her
sein kann.
Ich bin aufgestanden, ich bin aufs Klo gegangen, hab mich an den Rechner gesetzt, hab jetzt
zwei Brötchen gegessen, das kann ja eigentlich gar eineinhalb Stunden gedauert haben alles.
Ich hab mich auch nicht erst in meinen anderen Account eingeloggt, sondern direkt in den
Streaming-Account gestanden, das heißt ich hab irgendwie großartig was aufgemacht, geguckt
hab ich auch nicht.
Abmahn, ach ich hab Abmahn, Schmutz, Schmutz gelesen, ja ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Google Fonts Abmahnung verhindern, hey ich wollte unter das Video ein Link posten zu
einem Font-Projekt auf GitHub, also sprich wie man sich die Fonts am besten selbst hosten
kann, zumindest meiner Ansicht nach, aber ich hab ein GitHub-Link unter das Video gepostet
und dann hat YouTube gesagt, nein, das ist Spam, das darfst du nicht posten, also ich
durfte es posten, aber der Post war nicht da, dann hab ich es nochmal gepostet mit Leerzeichen
zwischen den Links, äh zwischen den Uhls, zwischen der Uhl, sodass es kein Link ist
und dann hat YouTube immer noch gesagt, nein, wird jetzt gesperrt, dann hab ich ihn mal
gefragt auf Twitter, sag mal, kann sein das YouTube das gesperrt hat, meinte er hat das
noch nicht mal im Spam-Freigeben-Ordner drin mein Comment, also es war so böse ein GitHub-Link
zu posten in den YouTube-Comments, dass YouTube gedacht hat, das muss man noch nicht mal freischaltbar
machen, ganz ganz schlimm, ja weil größere Content-Creator auf YouTube ja auch bekannt
dafür sind, böse Links unter Videos von anderen Leuten zu spammen, ich weiß nicht,
der YouTube-Algorithmus ist echt wild, wie man so schön sagt, es wäre mal an der Zeit
für Algorithmen verstehen, den YouTube-Algorithmus zu erklären, aber ich glaube da gerät er
auch an seine Grenzen, weil ich vermute mal selbst YouTube die Leute, die das da weiterentwickeln,
verstehen es nicht mehr, es ist wahrscheinlich die erste AI, die selbstständig geworden
ist, keiner versteht mal den YouTube-Algorithmus, sie macht irgendwas, aber keiner weiß warum,
irgendwann 2100 werden wir zurückgucken und sagen mit dem YouTube-Algorithmus hat alles
begonnen.
Oh Mann, morgen kann ich es essen, waren große Brötchen, nee noch nicht mal, das waren so
Tiefkühlbrötchen, ganz kleine Furzdinger, gibt es auf dem neuen PC Windows 11, das ist
eine sehr gute berechtigte Frage, wahrscheinlich schon, wahrscheinlich gibt es dann auf dem
neuen PC auch Windows 11 und dann müssen wir uns wahrscheinlich mal in 1-2 Streams
der Sache widmen, dass man den irgendwie, dass man Windows 11 irgendwie usable machen
kann.
Die nächste Frage ist, gibt es mittlerweile schon eine Möglichkeit die Windows Taskleiste,
die Windows 11 Taskleiste das Kopieren auszuschalten, irgendwelche Registry Hacks oder so, also
wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise Explorer starte mehrfach, dann habe ich mehrfach Explorer
am Start, das gibt es ja unter Windows 11 nicht mehr, weil Microsoft der Meinung ist,
jeder möchte es unbedingt, ganz wichtig, auch wenn Microsoft wissen müsste, dass man
mehr horizontalen Bildschirmplatz hat als vertikalen, aber gut, Microsoft denkt man
muss das kopieren, nee wenn, nee ich will schon Windows 11 haben, auch weil viele neuen
Sachen nur noch unter Windows 11 jetzt vielleicht noch nicht gehen, aber dann gehen werden,
nee es ist dann mal an der Zeit, neuer Rechner, neues Windows, das ist schon okay, dann wird
es halt mal Windows 11, ist jetzt nicht so als wäre Windows 11 so extrem viel unterschiedlich
zu Windows 10, ja, wie geht es der Katz, das ist eine gute Frage, ich weiß nicht, die
ist irgendwie, irgendwo liegt die jetzt und ich weiß nicht wo, also heute Morgen ging
es der noch gut, da ist die mir entgegengeflitzt, da musste ich mit ihr ins Bad, musste ihr
den Wasserhahn anmachen, meine Katze trinkt ja aus Prinzip am liebsten aus dem Wasserhahn
und tut so als müsste verdursten, wenn ich den Wasserhahn nicht anmache, wohlgemerkt,
die hat zwei Katzenbrunnen in der Wohnung verteilt, also im Haus verteilt und Trinknäpfchen
verteilt, aber die will trotzdem ein Wasserhahn und wenn ich den Wasserhahn nicht anmache,
dann ruft sie aus dem Bad so nach dem Motto, auf jetzt hier, Alter, wird mal Zeit, mach
mal an, ich bin hier am verdursten Wasserhahn, muss ich sagen, also heute Morgen ging es
der noch gut, jetzt geht es der wahrscheinlich auch noch gut, aber ich weiß nicht wo sie
rumgammelt, wahrscheinlich bei mir auf dem Schrank oder so, wie überwacht man am besten
einen Mail Server, ja das ist die Frage, was du von deinem Mail Server überwachen willst,
willst du deine Message Queue, willst du deine Mail Queue überwachen, da gibt es dann meistens
irgendwelche eingebauten Tools, um sich die Mail Queue Größe anzeigen zu lassen, kann
das bestimmt auch in irgendeinen Prometheus Exporter packen oder sowas, willst du quasi
so Black Box testen, also willst du quasi Mails verschicken über deinen Mail Server
und gleichzeitig gucken, ob die ankommen, das ist ja dann quasi nicht direktes Monitoring
vom Mail Server, sondern Funktion des Mail Servers, ja, Problem ist, dass es meist erst
zu spät auffällt, um es zu analysieren, ja, also das könntest du tatsächlich machen,
du könntest dir Mails schicken und gucken, ob die ankommen, ansonsten mein, du kannst
die üblichen Verdächtigen überwachen auf deinem Mail Server, du kannst das Log, kannst
das, also das Log würde ich auf jeden Fall irgendwo einliefern lassen, je nachdem wie
viel da durchgeht, sei es nur Ersus Logging, wir hinschreiben, ja, also Log Analyse, dann
kannst du die üblichen Verdächtigen von RAM Usage, Disk Usage, CPU Usage, Prozesse,
Forks, was auch immer machen, kannst deine Mail Queue, sei es überwachen, wie viele Mails
in der Mail Queue sind, ob sich das irgendwie aufstaut, ja, wenn du den Zeitpunkt nicht
richtig mitbekommst, ganz ehrlich, das einfachste wäre wahrscheinlich Mails schicken und gucken,
ob die ankommen, dann kannst du dir nämlich sicher sein, wenn die ankommen, dass alles
in Ordnung ist, wenn das halt nur so sporadische Fehler sind, dass dann so eine Mail von 1000
gedroppt wird, ja, dann habe ich keine Ahnung, dann hängt es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
vom Mail Server ab, dann müsste man sich was anderes überlegen,
also ich würde tatsächlich Log Analyse erstmal gucken, das Ding auf möglichst Verbose stellen,
heißt das eigentlich Verbose oder ist das Verbus, wie heißt denn das eigentlich,
Verbose, alles klar, wieder noch, so noch, gut, was auch immer, wenn Google das sagt,
dann muss das stimmen, also wir machen das mittlerweile auch so, das haben wir sogar im
Stream mal programmiert, so wie das, ja genau, also ich habe ja auch im Stream mal was programmiert,
was genau dafür da ist, also wir machen das auch mittlerweile so, also Hintergrund ist,
wir sind mal auf einer, wir sind nicht auf einer Spamliste gelandet, das ist falsch,
weil wenn wir auf einer Spamliste gelandet wären, dann könnte man das auch anderweitig abfragen,
ob man auf einer Spamliste ist oder nicht, wir wurden mal bei United Internet Raid Limited und
dann irgendwann auch temporär geblockt, weil irgendwelche Außendienstleute, keine Ahnung,
40.000 Geburtstags-Mails verschickt haben oder so, musst du dir vorstellen,
war halt einer der Meinung, er muss Geburtstags-Mails oder sowas schreiben,
gut zumindest, das ist halt nicht richtig aufgefallen und daraufhin haben wir gesagt,
wisst ihr, wir machen jetzt den Easy Mode, so wie wir es sicher mitbekommen, ob wir Raid
Limited oder geblockt sind, wir verschicken uns einfach Mails, wir verschicken uns selbst Mails,
wir verschicken aktuell Mails an Gmail, GMX und Web.de und über eine Stunde, also default Einstellungen,
so wie ich das gebaut habe, ist alle 10 Minuten schickt er eine Mail an diese drei Anbieter und
wenn er 10 Mails verschickt hat, also 10 Minuten nachdem er die 10te Mail verschickt hat, guckt
er dann per IMAP nach, ob die alle angekommen sind und wenn Anzahl der verschickten Mails gleich
der Anzahl der Received Mails auf allen Mail-Accounts ist, dann ist alles gut, ansonsten muss man sich
überlegen, was man machen will. Es gibt noch keine großen Alerts aktuell, aber was sie dann mit den
Prometheosmetriken machen, können sich ja überlegen. Aber so machen wir das auch, weil wir es oft
genug jetzt schon nicht mitbekommen haben und das mit dem Spam, mit dem wir wurden Raid Limited,
war jetzt halt in letzter Zeit, was so ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen hat,
deswegen habe ich gedacht, wir basteln da mal was. Löscht er die Mails auch von selbst wieder oder
läuft das IMAP Post von irgendwann? Ja, der löscht alle Mails, nachdem er seinen Rundlauf einmal
durch hat und geguckt hat, wie viele Mails angekommen sind, löscht er auch alle Mails wieder und für
den Fall der Fälle, das ist sogar richtig richtig sixhead, für den Fall der Fälle, dass Mails sehr
sehr langsam in der Zustellung sind, sodass quasi Mails verloren gehen, aber dann bei dem Check quasi
die Mails vom vorvorletzten Durchgang erst ankommen, bei Raid Limited, habe ich in jeder Mail eine
Unique ID stehen, die nur für diesen Durchlauf gültig ist und erzählt nur E-Mails, wo die Unique
ID stimmt, aber löschen tut er alle, das heißt, es müssen zehn Mails innerhalb von eineinhalb
Stunden angekommen sein und die müssen alle die passende Unique ID, UID enthalten und nur dann
zählt er die, alle andere nicht. Haben wir im Stream irgendwann mal angefangen zu bauen? Mittlerweile
läuft das bei uns, also läuft das bei mir auf der Arbeit live? Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Moin,
ich Pepega, habe mein Firmen-iPhone mit Authenticator aus Versehen, oh das ist doof.
Haben die keinen Backup? Wobei ich habe auch keinen Backup, Keckl, ich habe einen Backup mal
gemacht vor, also doch, ich habe einen Backup von vor einem Jahr oder so von meinem iPhone,
was aber für die Authenticator App, ne bringt auch nichts, ne bringt ja nichts, bringt ja nichts,
da wurde wahrscheinlich einiges danach geedit. Das ist übrigens auch noch was, was ich im Dezember
unbedingt machen muss und ich weiß immer noch nicht genau, was ich kaufen soll. Also es ist ja
eine durchaus, ein durchaus realistisches Szenario, dass ich nächstes Jahr nicht mehr dort arbeite,
wo ich jetzt arbeite und aktuell benutze ich das Firmen-iPhone, genauso wie Rosario. Allerdings,
wenn ich das Firmen-iPhone, also wenn ich kündige dort, kann ich das Firmen-iPhone nicht mehr
verwenden. Dementsprechend brauche ich ein eigenes Smartphone und ich brauche ein paar Monate Zeit,
weil ich mache ja darüber auch mit einigen Services zwei Faktor-Authentifizierung und
Authenticator und zum Beispiel für Hetzner-Login und so, die muss ich alle umziehen auf mein neues
Smartphone. Das kann ich jetzt nicht innerhalb von ein, zwei Wochen machen, weil ich vergesse,
garantiert irgendwas, wo ich mich nicht so oft einlogge. Das heißt, ich brauche dann schon so
ein, zwei Monate Zeit, das umzuziehen. Das heißt, ich müsste mir eigentlich jetzt mal ein Smartphone
kaufen und ich tendiere aktuell tatsächlich zum iPhone 14 Pro. Ich musste gerade überlegen,
aber iPhone 14 Pro nicht Max, sondern das mit 6,1-Toll-Display ist halt teuer as fuck. 1000-1200 Euro.
Das wird ein teurer Dezember, sage ich euch Leute. 4500 Euro Rechner, 1200 Euro Smartphone und vor
zwei Monaten 25.000 Euro Auto. Kackel. Ich brauche mehr Subs Leute, any primers. Doch ich, nee,
ich kaufe kein iPhone Max, auch wenn ich Max heiße. Nee, nee. Mir ist das, ich habe aktuell ein iPhone,
was sind das? iPhone 11? Ich glaube, ich habe aktuell ein iPhone 11. Das hat ja auch ein 6,1-Toll-Display
oder 6,07-Toll oder irgendwie sowas, aber das ist mir schon zu groß. Also nicht vom Display,
sondern vom Daumen her. Also wenn ich das halte, wenn ich das Smartphone halte und möchte
beispielsweise die Lampe anmachen oder auf den oder die Kamera aufmachen, da komme ich mit dem
Daumen richtig unten hin. Also das ist gerade, also 6,1-Toll ist gerade das, was ich einhändig
mit dem Daumen ordentlich bedienen kann. Also nicht mal ordentlich, was ich gerade so noch bedienen
kann. Hegen, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Hat schon funktioniert, ja, alles. Hawker Subscriptions.
Wie man liest, hat anscheinend vor allem der Workstation derzeit noch ein Problem mit dazu.
Ja, das werden sie schon auf die Reihe kriegen. Es gibt leider kein iPhone Mini mehr. Ja, ich
finde den 6,1-Toll-Bildschirm, ehrlich gesagt, gute Kombination. Ist wirklich groß genug, dass
es dich nicht stört. Ich gucke da auch abends im Bett, gucke ich da Livestreams drauf, obwohl
ich ein iPad habe. Reicht mir komplett. Im Bett hast du das ja eh nicht drei Meter wegstehen oder
so. Und größer wäre vielleicht cool rein zum Gucken, aber von der Bedienung her und für in
die Hose stecken, dann schon wieder doof, aber gerade von der Bedienung her. Aufs neue Monitor
zum Rechner wahrscheinlich nicht gleich. Wahrscheinlich erst später, weil ich da noch gucken muss.
Irgendein OLED-Display wird es aber werden. Das wird teuer, sage ich euch. Überlegt euch mein
neuer Rechner, iPhone, OLED-Display, bin ich bestimmt 6.000, 7.000 Euro nochmal los dieses Jahr. Muss
ich mehr Sellouts machen? Leute, ich mache noch mal Sellout demnächst. Hier, 16. bis 22. die Woche
mache ich noch mal Sellout für Gaming-Equipment, aber diesmal. Was hältst du von den neuen AMD-GPUs?
Naja, ist ja noch nicht wirklich belastbare Benchmarks und sowas raus. Es gibt so Abschätzungen
von ungefähr so 4090. AMD selbst sagt, es ist eher, sehen sie sich als Konkurrenz zu 4080,
was wahrscheinlich auch sinnvoller ist, weil viel mehr Leute sich eine 4080 kaufen werden,
wenn es denn dann eine gibt, lieferbar als eine 4090, aber man darf es nicht unterschätzen,
dass es ein gewisses Prestige hat, die schnellste Grafikkarte zu haben. Was ist Sellout? Zum
Beispiel, wenn ich Werbung mache bei mir für Genshin Impact oder wie ist das andere Ding?
Matchmasters oder sowas. Ich mache halt ein, wie nennt man das heutzutage? Ein Product Placement
nennt man das ja. Ich sage immer noch Sellout dazu. Man verkauft, Sellout ist glaube ich übersetzt,
was heißt denn Sellout übersetzt? Sowas wie man hat sich verkauft oder so. Wenn jemand ein Sellout
ist, dann hat er sich verkauft oder? Hat sich selbst ausverkauft. Also wenn ich Sellout mache,
dann habe ich halt mein, ja genau sowas. Habe ich meine Seele für 60 Sekunden verkauft. Was man
finde ich den Product Placements durchaus anhört. Aber Leute, ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht,
dass die Product Placements immer so bescheuert klingen. Ich habe bei Genshin und bei Matchmasters
am Anfang selbst einen Vorschlag gemacht für den Text. Und beides wollten sie nicht haben. Beides
haben sie gesagt, nee nee, nimm mal lieber unser offizielles Skript und dementsprechend hört sich
das halt noch an. Oh, Matchmasters hat noch gar nicht bezahlt glaube ich. Ich glaube ich habe
den noch gar nicht gerechnet. Sekunde, Sekunde, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken. Moment, wo ist
mein Handy? App. Banking App. Aha, aha. Aber Genshin haben sie bezahlt, das ist gut. Ja,
keine Ahnung. Noch nicht. Klang wie eine Präsentation in der 7. Klasse. Also ich finde,
dann hast du relativ gut präsentiert, wenn das in der 7. Klasse bei dir schon so klang. Also wenn
ich an die Präsentationen denke, die ich mir da in der Schule anhören musste, die waren einfach
alle nur schlecht. Meine eingenommen. Jetzt machen eigentlich die Stonks Leute. Moment, ich muss mal
kurz Aktien checken. Stonks diesen Monat plus 396 Euro. Aber das ist letztendlich egal, weil
dieses Jahr ist minus 1589 Euro und 34 Cent. Also dieses Jahr waren die Stonks eher Not Stonks.
Ein gebrauchtes Vorgänger iPhone, nee. Tja, also dieses Jahr war eher Stonks Verlust angesagt.
Wie viel Prozent sind das? Das ist eine gute Frage. Das steht da gar nicht. Gibt keine,
gibt keine Prozent. Ah, hier im Moment. Prozent, doch, nee. Doch, minus 8,1 Prozent im letzten Jahr.
Minus 8,1 Prozent. Das geht doch noch. Ja, das ist auch nur so wenig, weil es halt ein World ETF
ist und dementsprechend, dass das langsam hoch und langsam runtergeht. Aber dieses Jahr ging es
halt zum größten Teil einfach nur runter. Was aber nicht so schlimm ist, weil ich habe fast,
als es am tiefsten Stand war, vor zwei Wochen ungefähr, es war im Juni war es noch mal ein
bisschen tiefer, fast als es auf dem tiefsten Stand war, habe ich noch mal 8000 Euro gekauft.
So, ab jetzt kann es wieder hochgehen. Aber das Dumme ist, wahrscheinlich geht es noch weiter runter.
Ups, habe ich jetzt gedrückt. Hey Max, was geht? Wie war deine Woche? Wie war meine Woche? Lass
mal kurz überlegen. Wie war meine Woche? Ich habe eine Bewerbung abgeschickt und ich habe auch schon
eine Antwort gekriegt, dass es demnächst Einladungen gibt. Ging wahnsinnig schnell.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Bewerbungen hochgeladen, also Bewerbungen per Mail geschickt und hatte
irgendwie zwei Tage später die Ansage, die Antwort schon, dass jetzt Einladung kommt.
Also aus der Gesichtspunkt ganz gut. Viele Punkte bei mir auf der Arbeit gehen mir immer noch auf
den Keks, weil halt Homeoffice und gewollte Anwesenheitspflicht und sowas. Ich habe übrigens gemerkt,
wie krass meine Effektivität oder, nee, nicht Effektivität nennt man das, meine Arbeitsleistung
im Endeffekt drunter leidet, kein Homeoffice mehr zu haben. Ich habe mal geguckt, was ich diese Woche
hingekriegt habe. Es war wirklich fast nichts. Zu geil. Dienstag bin ich auf die Arbeit gefahren,
war müde als Fuck, weil ich halt wieder 6.30 Uhr schon und die Bahn wieder nicht gekommen ist
unterwegs war. Ich war im Gefühl den halben Tag im Halbschlaf und eigentlich nur mehr oder
weniger gemietet. Dienstag ein bisschen. Mittwochs noch müde gewesen vom Dienstag. Tatsächlich ein
bisschen was gemacht, aber auch hauptsächlich gemietet. Mittwochs war der einzige Tag,
wo ich wirklich ganz normal von morgens bis mittags was Sinnvolles gemacht habe, wenn auch
nicht durchgängig. Du kannst dich schlecht 8 Stunden am Stück komplett konzentrieren. Mittwochs
habe ich wirklich, der einzige Tag, wo ich was richtig Sinnvolles war. Nicht Mittwochs,
Schwachsinn. Donnerstag, Donnerstag, Mittwochs nicht. Donnerstag, der einzige Tag, wo ich wirklich
richtig viel gemacht habe, da war ich wieder fit und es waren nicht so viele Meetings.
Ja und Freitag hatte ich dünne Schüsse. Da habe ich auch nichts gemacht. Also ich habe die Woche
nicht sonderlich viel gemacht. Aber ich habe eine Bewerbung abgeschickt und Antwort bekommen. War
gespannt. Wie schätzt du die Entwicklung von Twitter ein? Ganz im Ernst? Ich glaube, da wird
ein bisschen zu sehr aktuell der Weltuntergang prophezeit. Ich meine, es ist einiges ein bisschen
fragwürdig. Zum Beispiel habe ich gelesen, dass jetzt alle Werbepartner, die keinen Bock mehr auf
Twitter haben, Public geschämt werden sollen. Also fragt man sich auch, was zum Teufel geht mit dem
Kerl ab. Ich meine, du kannst doch nicht auf der einen Seite sagen, ja hier Redefreiheit und alles,
was ich gut finde, muss ich nochmal betonen, was ich gut finde. Aber dann auf der anderen Seite,
wenn sich jemand aus freien Stücken dazu entscheidet, nicht mehr werben zu wollen,
dann muss man den Public schämen oder wie oder was. Also die Logik, die verstehe ich nicht so genau.
Also es ist natürlich nicht, es ist eigentlich wie immer. Es ist nicht alles geil und nicht
alles schlecht. Manche Reaktionen finde ich persönlich ziemlich übertrieben. Zum Beispiel,
dass schon bei der pure Ankündigung, dass hier Elon jetzt ins Twitter Hauptquartier einmarschiert
ist, die ersten deutschen Politiker gesagt haben, ich ziehe mich von dieser Plattform zurück. Warum?
Twitter ist immer nach wie vor eine super Plattform, um mit dem gemeinen Volk zu
kommunizieren. Wenn auch wahrscheinlich meistens die Leute gar nicht selbst twittern,
sondern irgendwelche Social Media Teams, aber trotzdem. Warum weiß ich davon? Ich bin in
Andorra. Manchmal fliege ich auch kurz rüber. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, wo wollen sie denn
sonst hin? Es gibt doch nichts Vergleichbares zu Twitter für solche Sachen. Wollen die jetzt zu
Instagram? Ach Quatsch, das ist doch nicht für die Masse ganze Knicken. Guck mal, mein Trump hat
Geld und gewisse Popularität gehabt und er hat auch versucht, irgendwas mit seiner eigenen Plattform,
ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie das Ding heißt, da zu reißen und das weiß ich, da ist
doch auch keiner wirklich hingegangen. True Social Hisasaw. Kann ja durchaus sein,
dass der bald wieder am Start ist auf Twitter. Ja, ist auch nicht besser, oder? Ist auch nicht
besser. Also es gibt ja da keine wirkliche Alternative zu. So. Die Masse ist auch nicht
auf Twitter. Moment, es geht nicht um die Gesamtheit der Menschheit, es geht um das,
wie es aktuell auf Twitter ist. Also es geht ja explizit um Twitter, nicht um die Gesamtheit
Menschheit. Wenn du die Gesamtheit Menschheit anguckst, dann ist die Gesamtheit Menschheit
wahrscheinlich kaum irgendwo, weil die China-Chinesen sind auf WeChat und auf ihrem komischen Panda,
ne wie heißt das? Keine Ahnung, also das ist ja auch sehr verteilt. Wie heißt denn ihr Google?
Baidu, Baidu, oder? Baidu? Ist Baidu nicht den ihr Facebook oder ihr Google oder wie war das?
Baidu. Das ist die Suchmaschine, das ist das China-Chinesen-Google. Weibo gibt es auch,
ich kenne nur Baidu. Man kann auch in die Baidu-Cloud, wenn man will. Leute, also falls einer mal in die
Baidu-Cloud will, gucken wir uns mal an, was die Baidu-Cloud kostet. Cloud Service, Disk,
Baidu AI Cloud, Infinite Possibilities. Okay, zeig her. I-Speed-Seite, Preise. Das machen sie
schon mal wie die Großen, das machen sie schon mal wie die Großen, keine Preise hinschreiben,
keine Preise. Preise sind outdated, Preise schreibt man bei Cloud nicht hin. Gutes Times New Roman und
kaputte, kaputte Fonts. Preis, Baidu Cloud. Ja, aber ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt,
wie sich das entwickelt. Den Weltuntergang sehe ich da allerdings nicht. Genauso 100%ig diese
Sache mit blauer Haken soll kostenpflichtig werden und sowas. So sehr verstehe ich die Aufregung
darum, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Es ist halt die Frage, was hinten dranhängt. Wenn 8 Euro bedeutet,
es ist halt in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Verifizierungsprozess. Der blaue Haken,
der sollte ja eigentlich nur eins bedeuten, dass es der echte Account quasi ist. Also,
dass quasi die Person, die man mit dem Account verbindet, auch derjenige ist,
der zu dem der Account gehört. So, und ich meine, das kann jeder Hinz und Kunst ja theoretisch sich
verifizieren lassen, weil das interessiert halt keinen. Ob das jetzt so der Verkaufsschlager wird,
habe ich auch mal meine Zweifel, weil ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, ich habe bis heute keinen
blauen Haken bei Twitter und juckt mich auch überhaupt nicht, ob ich einen blauen Haken habe
bei Twitter oder nicht. Also, was ich wichtiger finde, ist auf, weil auf Twitter siehst du ja
wenigstens immer genau, wer was ist und wer was schreibt. Da gibt es ja auch Namen nur einmal.
Auf YouTube, auf YouTube ist es tatsächlich relativ wichtig, dass man den Verified Haken hat,
denn auf YouTube kann sich jeder Max FPS nennen oder jeder, gibt es nach Kronk oder so nennen,
und sich sogar das gleiche Bild wie Kronk und Max machen oder wie ApoRed und gut,
ob sich heute noch einer großartig ApoRed faked, weiß man nicht. Aber könnten alle machen.
Oder Inscope oder so. Also kannst du auf YouTube easy faken. Und wenn du nicht gerade über den
Avatar bzw. den Channel gehst und dann feststellst, das ist aber gar nicht der echte, dann hast du
Pech. Deswegen ist dieser Verified Haken auf YouTube, finde ich, wichtig, weil auf YouTube
sehr, sehr einfach Identitäten faken kannst. Aber auf Twitter, ganz ehrlich, wen juckt?
Der kritische Hase gibt ein neues Video von ApoRed. Das letzte hat mir schon gereicht,
das Genshin Impact. Wobei wir haben ja gar nicht das ApoRed Genshin Impact Video geguckt,
sondern dieses Meta Video über seinen Genshin Sponsoring. Wobei ich da immer noch sagen muss,
ich weiß nicht, was da alles gelaufen ist, aber dass ein Cutter irgendwelches privates
Video Footage liegt, gehört sich eigentlich nicht. Gut, wer weiß, was dahinter alles passiert ist.
Vielleicht hat er ihn nicht bezahlt, was auch immer, keine Ahnung. Aber an sich finde ich das keine
gute Aktion. Ja, Trump schreibt viel, wenn er taglang ist. Beziehungsweise erzählt viel. Er hat
auch erzählt, dass man Desinfektionsmittel zu sich nehmen soll. Da kann man das nicht so viel
drauf geben. Ja, die jetzt teilweise auch wegrennen. Und alle Werbepartner, die wegrennen,
sollen jetzt ja publik geschämt werden, dass sie wegrennen. Ja, warum nicht? Wie gesagt,
ich finde es nicht verkehrt, diesen Verifizierungshaken für alle anzubieten. Ob das jetzt der Renner wird,
habe ich meine Zweifel. Weiß jemand, wie man Daten auf dem Heap in C++ speichert? Ja,
einfach nicht auf dem Stack speichern. Aus meiner Sicht dürfte das relativ einfach sein.
Also, ich kenne mich zwar nicht so mit Speichermanagement von C++ aus, aber aus meiner
Ansicht dürfte es relativ einfach sein. Alles, was du nicht lokal in deiner Funktion definierst,
ist auf dem Heap. Und alles, was du lokal in deiner Funktion definierst, ist auf dem Stack.
Also sprich, das, was automatisch aufgeräumt wird danach und ich nicht darum kümmern muss,
ist auf dem Stack und der Rest ist auf dem Heap, wo du selbst manuelles Memory-Management,
sagen wir mal, es geht ja auch so was wie smarte Pointer und so was in C++ mittlerweile. Ja,
genau. Und im Prinzip ist es, wenn du new verwendest, wenn du globale Variablen,
wahrscheinlich, vermute ich mal, keine Ahnung, in welche globalen Variablen verwendest und
new verwendest, ja, so würde ich das sagen. Also zumindest rate ich das mal so, bei C++
weiß man ja nie, aber klingt sinnvoll. Also alles, was länger lebt, als deine Funktion
ausgeführt wird, ist auf dem Heap, weil ansonsten wird es ja nicht funktionieren. Sonst wäre es ja weg.
Könntest du mich hochladen? Geile Kombination aus Name und Text. Das
Breitbandausbauvideo möchte hochgeladen werden. Ja, könnte ich machen, aber ich habe es noch nicht
fertig aufgenommen. Ich finde das übrigens toll, dass du einen Twitch-Name gemacht hast,
der sich wahrscheinlich nur darauf bezieht, dass ich vor drei Monaten gesagt habe,
ich will ein Video hochladen zum Breitbandausbau. High IQ Twitch-Name. Ja. Wobei ja die C++ Leute
jetzt sagen, nein, du darfst new nicht mehr verwenden. New ist ganz, ganz böse. Ich habe
es immer noch nicht so genau verstanden, warum. Heutzutage rappen die das lieber in 30 Smart
Pointer, dass die Zeile anstatt so lang, so lang ist. Aber okay. C++ versteht eh keiner.
Wann kommt das nächste agile Jobstellen-Angebot-Video? Da muss ich mal gucken,
wird mal echt, wird echt mal wieder Zeit. Ich habe letztens wieder ein richtig
Abschreckungs-C++-Abschreckungs-Video gesehen. Wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an,
ich möchte, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch nur mal Best Cases. Auch das ist was für mich,
das muss ich, das müssen wir gleich gucken. Best Cases. Müssen wir mal gucken, brauche ich,
brauche ein Best Cases. C++-Jason-Conference-Talk. Nope. C++-conf. Hallo? C++-conf. Hier. So. Das
gucken wir nicht. Keine Sorge. Das gucken wir nicht. Ich will euch nur mal ein abschreckendes
Beispiel zeigen, was in C++ als toll empfunden wird und sogar in einem offiziellen Conference
Talk vorkommt. Achtung. Kurz Vorspul, das ist alles abartig, aber zum Beispiel, es geht schon
los. Zum Beispiel sowas. Wobei das jetzt gesagt noch geht, das geht noch deutlich schlimmer.
Wo war denn das? Hier. Guckt euch das mal an. Kek, Alter. Was ist das für eine Sündung
schon wieder? Nee, Moment, das ist gar nicht das, was ich mache. Naja, doch teilweise. Teilweise
schon. Guckt euch das mal an. Was zum? Das meinte ich. Das meinte ich.
Das meinte ich. Guckt euch das mal an hier. What the hell? Was bin ich hier sehend? Was
soll das überhaupt sagen? Guckt euch das mal an. Gibt es irgendjemand, der wirklich sich
das anguckt und sagt, ach ja, er obend, wie es was hier passiert? Okay, also das einzige,
was ich checke ist, dass es eine Konstexpr ist. Das bedeutet, es ist Compile-Time. So. Aber
jetzt ist vorbei. Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber anscheinend löst man damit irgendwelche
JSON-Probleme. Und wisst ihr, was der größte Witz ist? Soll ich euch mal einen Witz an
C++ erzählen, an der Standard Library? Die Standard Library von C++ hat im Jahr 2022
keinen JSON-Parser und jetzt haltet euch mal fest, keinen HTTP-Klein. Ich glaube, ich
weiß gar nicht, ob Sockets Teil der Standard Library sind. Nee, glaubt nicht, oder? Also
die C++-Standard Library hat keinerlei Networking. Muss man sich mal vorstellen. Schöne Programmiersprache,
die jetzt in Version 2023 rauskommt. Ich meine, wer braucht heutzutage schon HTTP und JSON-Serializing
und Deserializing? Das ist ja komplett, komplett overrated. Ja, und wenn jetzt irgendjemand
sagt, braucht man nicht, Sockets kommen aus dem Betriebssystem her dann. Ja, das ist ja
schön und gut, wenn ihr aus dem Betriebssystem her dann kommt. Aber warum gibt es keine einheitliche,
sei es nur irgendeinen Wrapper in der Standard Library, dass man es eben überall ordentlich
gleichermaßen verwenden kann? Und wenn jetzt einer sagt, ja, aber das liegt doch daran,
dass C++ überall laufefähig sein muss, also auch auf Microcontroller und sonst was, naja,
du kannst ja ohne Probleme auch Funktionen, also man kann es ja auch in die Standard Library
einen HTTP-Klein packen und wenn deine Plattform aus welchen Gründen auch immer keine Netzwerkkommunikation
erlaubt, dann ist es da halt nicht implementiert, beziehungsweise es gibt eine Exception oder
es gibt was auch immer, irgendetwas definiertes, ja. Aber nachdem so ziemlich jede Plattform,
außer vielleicht jetzt irgendwelche Microcontroller für Industriesteuerung, irgendwas mit Netzwerk
am Hut haben, naja. Also PaaS in der Standard Library kannst du ohne Probleme einen HTTP-Request
machen. Wie du einen HTTP-Request in C++ machst? Du musst ja eine der 1000 C++ HTTP-Libraries
raussuchen. Wahrscheinlich hast du Glück und deine jeweilige Plattform, zum Beispiel wenn
du für einen ESP32 machst, hat schon einen eingebauten HTTP-Klein. Also die ESP32-Hersteller-Library
bringt das schon mit. Leider, leider nur komplett in C oder Arduino hat, Arduino? Hat Arduino
einen Webklein standardmäßig? Weiß ich gar nicht. Ja in C, in C ist klar, also das
ist in C, ach in C++. Lipcurl. Wie gesagt, warum ist sowas nicht in der Standard Library
drin? Das verstehe ich nicht. Schau mal was von Code-Interview. Du meinst, ob du den Binary-Tree
inverten kannst? Ob ich schon mal ein Code-Interview machen musste? Nö. Ich musste aber eh kaum
Interviews machen, weil ich musste ein Vorstellungsgespräch machen. Bei meiner Ausbildung. Da ging es
nicht um irgendwelche Programmiersachen, da ging es halt um mein DSL-Anschluss, was ich
damit schon gebastelt habe und so Dinge. Was war das für eine Ausbildung? So, dann haben
die mich übernommen nach der Ausbildung, da musste ich kein Vorstellungsgespräch mehr
führen. Dann bin ich gewechselt zur Bank nach Frankfurt, wo ich jetzt arbeite. Da musste
ich auch kein richtiges Vorstellungsgespräch mehr führen, weil ich die Leute schon kannte.
Das einzige, wo ich Gespräche geführt habe, tatsächlich, ist noch nicht lange her. Einmal
bei dem letzten Laden, wo es leider nichts geworden ist, Corona bedingt, habe ich ein,
es war nicht wirklich kein richtiges Interview, das war so ein halbes Vorstellungsgespräch.
Da ging es aber auch nicht darum, programmieren wir was und jetzt, irgendwann nächste Woche
oder so, oder wann auch immer das genau ist. Aber ich denke auch nicht, dass ich da irgendwas
programmieren muss. Mal schauen, weiß ich nicht, habe ich noch nicht gemacht. Aber im
Zweifelsfall kann ich den Binary Tree inverten, das ist gut. Einzige, was ich kann, Binary
Trees inverten. Ja, da kann man sich jetzt tatsächlich drüber streiten. Es gibt ja
unterschiedliche Ansätze, aber ich finde es gut, wenn die Standard Library umfangreich
ist. Einfach, weil es da nicht die JavaScript-Problematik gibt. Ist odd und is even als Package und
in 250.000 Projekten als Abhängigkeit. Und weil es einen Weg gibt, wie es zu 90% gemacht
wird, wenn das Standard Library Zeug ausreicht. In Rust ist es auch so, die Rust Standard Library
hat teilweise coole Sachen. Die haben Channel-Implementierung, die haben UTF-8-String-Support, der richtig
gut ist im Vergleich zu anderen Sprachen, wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal C++ anguckt
oder auch.NET. Und der UTF-8-Support in.NET ist jetzt wirklich net so der Wahnsinn. Aber
vieles hat Rust in der Standard Library auch nicht. Also ich glaube, du kannst in der
Standard Library von Rust auch kein HTTP-Request machen, oder? Nee, kannst du auch nicht machen.
Also Rust ist auch sehr minimalistisch. Wobei Rust halt auch eine Sprache ist, die explizit
sagt, sie sind, also sie wollen auch lauffähig sein ohne ihre Standard Library. Du kannst
ja Rust auch ohne Rust Standard Library kompilieren, wenn du halt nur Sachen verwendest, die andere
anderen da sind. Ja, aber wie gesagt, finde ich auch kein großer Fan von, ich mag das,
wenn Standard Library technisch alles enthält, was man so, ich verwende in.NET auch viele
externen Libraries, ja, für irgendwelche Units zu konvertieren. Ich verwende übrigens
auch immer noch gerne json.net anstatt den Standard Json-Parser in.NET. Also ist da
auch nicht alles rosig. Aber zumindest ist da HTTP-Klein drin. Und noch nicht mal den
verwende ich hauptsächlich verwende ich auch einen Wrapper für den HTTP-Klein. Aber zumindest
ist vieles in der.NET Standard Library drin und man braucht keine extra Libraries. Und
was musst du eigentlich hier für machen? libcurl muss ja dann installiert sein auf dem
System. Oder du musst das irgendwie statisch kompilieren und so und so. Hast schon wieder
irgendwelche Dependencies drinne. So blöds klingt und eines der größten Vorteile früher
unter Linux war, so nach dem Motto, dass du einen ordentlichen Package Manager hast, ich
persönlich bin mittlerweile ein richtig großer Fan von Self-Contained Applications. Bisschen
wie das Go macht. Nur, dass ich Go als Sprache nicht übermäßig geil finde. Aber ich finde
das gut, wenn du ein Binary hast oder ein Folder, wo alles drin ist, was du brauchst, du startest
das einfach und es läuft rückwirkend bis Linux 2.32 Kernel oder so..NET hat ein paar
Probleme bei ganz alten Linux-Distros. Ich glaube.NET ist rückwirkend laufe ich bis
so ungefähr Ubuntu 14.04 oder so was oder 12.04. Irgendwie 10 Jahre alt. Das dürfte
in Ordnung sein, ja das kann man. Ach, ich muss ehrlich sagen C++ hat schon, auch wenn
ich viele, aber hat durchaus auch paar coole Sachen. Also, ich flame ja oft über C++,
dann soll ich euch mal ein paar Sachen sagen, die ich tatsächlich gut finde an C++. Eine
Sache, die ich gut finde an C++ ist, aber das liegt hauptsächlich daran, weil es einfach
absoluter Bullshit war früher, ist die neue String Formatting Library, die allerdings
noch kaum einen Compiler implementiert. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich immer noch die
Library von GitHub importieren, anstatt einfach das aus der Standard Library zu verwenden.
Aber, dass sie überhaupt eine ordentliche String Formatting Library mittlerweile in der
Standard Library haben, finde ich schon mal gut. Die ist zwar, naja, ganz ok, sehr stark
von der Python String Library, also hier, C++ FMT. Dieses Ding ist mittlerweile in der
Standard Library, FMT-Lib, seit C++ 20, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es kaum einen Compiler
gibt, die großartig implementiert, ja. Also, du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel sowas machen
in C++, guck mal. So Art String Interpolation. So Art, ja. Guck mal, sowas, ja. Also, zum
ersten Mal, dass man nicht mehr C out oder Print F oder so einen Rotz machen muss, vom
letzten Jahrtausend, sondern wirklich ordentlich mal sein Zeug formatieren kann. Sogar mit
Colors und sowas. Obwohl, ich glaube, Colors sind nicht in der Standard Library. Also,
das ist eine Sache, die finde ich tatsächlich, ist ganz gut. Ne, eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich
gut an C++ finde, die ich gut und schlecht an C++ finde, sind Templates. Templates an
sich Ausgeburt der Hölle. Es wird viel zu viel Template Magic gemacht. TypeScript ist
übrigens auf einem ähnlichen Weg. Ich habe letztens gesehen, irgendeiner hat eine Regex
Engine, eine Regex Engine rein in TypeScript, Types programmiert. Eine rudimentäre Regex
Engine rein in TypeScript, Type Definitions. Frag mir nicht, wie das geht. Gab es letztens
irgendwas auf Hacker News? Also, ganz vieles Zeug. Zumindest Templates haben eine coole
Sache, die ich wirklich, wirklich nice finde, was mir so in vielen anderen Sprachen, also
was ich nicht aus vielen anderen Sprachen kenne. Zum Beispiel kannst du in Templates,
oder nicht nur in Templates, stimmt gar nicht. Das ist Blödsinn, hat ja gar nichts mit Templates
zu tun. Compile Time Expressions, das finde ich in C++ tatsächlich ganz nice. Also, mir
fällt keine andere Sprache so spontan ein, wo du zum Beispiel sagen kannst. Das ist eine
Funktion, die akzeptiert ein Character Array, also einen String. Allerdings möchte ich
zur Compile Zeit checken, dass niemand, der die Funktion aufruft, mehr als ein String
übergibt, der länger als 15 Zeichen ist. Das geht mit Compile Time Expressions in C++.
Das geht natürlich auch nur, solange du nicht dynamisch da was dispatchst und aufrufst zur
Runtime. Das muss alles zur Compile Zeit vorliegen. Aber das kannst du in C++ machen. Du kannst
zum Beispiel in C++ checken, dass du keine Strings länger als 15 Zeichen übergibst an
der Funktion. Das finde ich ganz nice. Also Compile Time Expressions ist was cooles in
C++. Sieht zwar im Endeffekt abartig aus, aber von der Idee her finde ich es nice und
mir fällt auch keine andere Sprache ein, die das in dem Umfang kann. Also es ist nicht
alle schlecht an C++, aber fast alles. Ich habe schon immer gern programmiert. Schon
auch lange vor meiner Ausbildung. Schon immer gerne gemacht. Also das erste, eines der allerallersten
Sachen, die ich je programmiert habe, war ein Tool für das MMO, was ich damals gespielt
habe. Obwohl ich kann es euch erzählen, das ist ja nichts Schlimmes. Ich habe damals Dark
Age of Camelot gespielt, bestes MMO aller Zeiten. Der Hersteller kam damals auf die Idee,
dass es böse ist, dass man das Spiel Alt Tabben kann. Überlegt euch mal. Es gab eine Zeit,
da haben die Alt Tab ausgeschaltet, damit man keine Cheats im Hintergrund laufen lassen
kann. Ich wollte aber im Hintergrund zumindest mal Musik starten stoppen und sowas. Also
was habe ich gemacht? Ich habe ein Chatlogger Tool programmiert. Man konnte nämlich Chatlog
einschalten und das Spiel hat dann den Chat quasi protokolliert in der Datei und ich
habe die Datei einfach eingelesen in regelmäßigen Abständen und habe geschaut, ob ich irgendetwas
im Chat geschrieben habe. Das heißt ich konnte dann zum Beispiel in-game schreiben sowas
weiß ich, Player next oder sowas. Wenn ich das in-game geschrieben habe, hat nach ein
paar Sekunden das mein Programm im Chatlog erkannt und konnte dann die Musik eins weiter,
konnte dann quasi die Tastendruck simulieren für Musik weiter und sowas. Also es war was
relativ simples, rudimentäres, aber das war der Grund, warum ich mich damals angefangen
habe mit Programmieren zu beschäftigen. Ich habe davor schon ein bisschen rumgewurstet,
ja, aber das ist lange her. Man muss sagen, das kam 2001 oder so raus, ja, irgendwie 2002.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es da AutoHotKey überhaupt schon gegeben hat. Aber ganz davon
abgesehen AutoHotKey, weiß nicht, ob das damals Lockdateien überwachen konnte und
sonst was. Also es war irgendwie 2002 rum. Das war der Hauptgrund, warum ich angefangen
habe, mich mit Programmieren zu beschäftigen, weil ich abgefuckt war, dass sie mir verboten
haben, Alt-Tab zu machen im Game. Bisschen später habe ich dann eine Software gefunden,
wo du jede Fullscreen-Anwendung in Windows packen konntest und das Spiel auch so dann
Window-Mode lief. Aber das war das erste, das war das erste, warum ich mich ein bisschen
mit Programmieren beschäftigt habe. Und von da habe ich eigentlich festgestellt, ist
doch ganz nice und macht Bock. Ja, das predatet noch AutoHotKey. Das waren auch die Zeiten,
wenn man Videos gecaptchert hat. Wisst ihr, mit was man damals Videos gecaptchert hat,
Leute? So ziemlich der einzige Videocapturer, den es damals gab und der es wirklich übelster
Müll gewesen ist. FRAPS, richtig, nicht Hypercam, FRAPS, FRAPS gab es damals. Du konntest entweder
FRAPS-Captchern in Full-Size vom Display, was kein Rechner der Welt damals handeln konnte,
auch IO von der Festplatte und so nicht, oder Half-Size und das sah kacke aus. Ich verstehe
bis heute nicht, warum FRAPS nicht einfach eine normale Auflösung geboten hat. Danach
gab es ein paar andere Tools, aber FRAPS, ja. Ich habe damals ein paar Daug-Videos gemacht
mit FRAPS, ja. Gibt es immer noch auf YouTube, aber zeige ich euch jetzt nicht, weil man
das irgendwie mit mir persönlich dann in Verbindung bringen könnte. Ja, weil dann findet
man nämlich zum Beispiel, also wenn man meinen Username kennt aus dem Video, dann findet
man meinen In-Game-Character, meinen In-Game-Characters findet man. Und dann findet man wahrscheinlich
auch noch eine Bilder-Seite, wo damals die Leute Real-Life-Fotos geschert haben. Also
quasi, es war so eine, es war quasi ein, nennen wir es mal Tinder für MMOs, übertrieben gesagt.
Dann konntest du damals deine Real-Life-Bilder scheren und verbinden mit deinem In-Game-Character,
was du wusstest, wer so dahintersteht. Gatschi-Buzz-Videos, nein, nicht wirklich. FRAPS aktuelle Version.
Ja, FRAPS, aber wer es nicht kennt, FRAPS. Jawoll, FRAPS Test-Version. FRAPS. Du bist
einfach mal das erste, das erste Far Cry ist, was die captchern. By the way, das erste Far
Cry sah wirklich damals absolut bombastisch aus. FRAPS Review, was geht mit euch ab? How
to use FRAPS. Ich glaube FRAPS ist eines der einfachsten Software überhaupt gewesen. Warum
man dafür eine Anleitung braucht, ich weiß es nicht. Guck, das waren die einzigen Display-Settings,
die man, Dextory gab es da noch, ja, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern. Du konntest
nur Full-Size oder Half-Size von deiner Bildschirmauflösung aufnehmen. Das heißt, wenn du captchern wolltest,
sodass dein Rechner das schafft, musstest du runterstellen auf 800 x 600 oder so. Weil,
ganz ehrlich, 30 FPS, Full-Size, Full-Size war damals sowas wie, was hat man gespielt,
1600 x 900 oder sowas. Oder was war denn, was war hier? Was gab es denn für 4 zu 3 Auflösungen,
die beliebt waren? Ja, hier. 1280 x 960 oder 1440 x 1000, ne. Ja, doch das oder das. Genau,
600 x 1200 war es. Und das konntest du halt im Leben nicht captchern mit Fraps. Und selbst
Half-Size sah halt kacke aus. Deswegen musstest du dann runterstellen auf 1024 x Full-Size,
das war immer noch... Leute, die Zeit war echt nicht schön. Ganz ehrlich, richtig abadig.
Ne, 4 zu 3 Auflösungen, nicht 16 zu 9. So, jetzt gucken wir mal ein bisschen Videos. Genug
geschwätzt. In was ist Fraps gebroggert? Ich hätte jetzt instinktiv gesagt, wahrscheinlich
C, aber es könnte auch Pascal oder sowas gewesen sein. Fraps Programming Language.
Written. Written in Rust. Placingly fast Fraps. Ne, damals hat noch keiner an Rust gedacht.
DirectX OpenGL Sources. Ja, weiß man in welcher Programmiersprache? Weiß man in was Fraps
programmiert wurde? Ist OBS Better? Ja. Gab es damals schon Hardware-Encoder-Unterstützung?
Nö. Gab es nicht. War alles Software. War alles CPU. Allerdings muss man sagen, Fraps
hat es relativ clever gemacht. Wisst ihr, wie Fraps das mit dem Encoding gemacht hat?
Wisst ihr... Ne, das war nicht das Problem. Wisst ihr, wie Fraps das mit dem Encoding gemacht
hat? Warum Fraps überhaupt in der Lage war, damals Videos in Full-Size und 30 FPS zu Capture?
Genau, es hat nämlich einfach so gut wie gar kein Encoding gemacht. Das hat fast mehr
oder weniger RAW die Bilder gespeichert. Und dementsprechend war das Encoding kein Problem,
aber die Festplatte konnte das halt nicht. Du hattest damals ratzfatz Gigabyteweise Fraps
Aufnahmen. Und das konnte halt damals keine Festplatte handeln. Deswegen musstest du
eigentlich Half-Size recorden, was dann wieder kacke aussah. Oder du hast auf einer kleinen
Auflösung gespielt, wo du dann wieder nicht richtig spielen konntest. Also das war wirklich,
glaubt mir, das war, was Game Capture angeht, keine gute Zeit.
Ein Kollege von mir damals, mit dem ich zusammen täglich MMO gegrindet habe, der hat damals
für die Bravo Screen Fun gearbeitet. Kennt das irgendwie noch jemand? Bravo Screen Fun?
Das gab's mal, das war so was wie die Games, da nur von Bravo.
Ballermänner, hinein ins Abenteuer, alles klar. Bravo Screen Fun. Und der hatte damals ein
Tape Capture Device. Also das war ein Video Capturing Device, quasi so das Elgato von
2003. Das war so ein Teil, das hast du angeschlossen an PC und das hat dann aufgenommen in so einer
ganz scheppen Auflösung. In PAL Auflösung. Was für eine Auflösung hat PAL? 720? Genau.
720 x 576 hat das aufgenommen. Das war mit Bändern drinne. Das war ein Recorder mit
Bändern. Und dann, also du konntest das, du konntest dann quasi aufnehmen ohne Performance
einboosen am PC. Das hat er damals von der Arbeit mitgebracht, weil die mussten halt
damals für die Screen Fun auch Videos Capture und sowas. Und das hat er mitgenommen, dass
wir ein bisschen PVP Videos aufnehmen konnten. Und er hat halt gespielt in was weiß ich wahrscheinlich
so wie ich irgendwie 1600 x 1200. Und der hat das halt in PAL Auflösung gecaptured dieses
Device dann vom PC, frag mich nicht wie es genau funktioniert hat. Und das sah halt schwammig
als Fuck aus danach. Aber du konntest halt ohne Performance einboosen Capture. War halt richtig
geil. Und danach musstest du, also du musstest erstmal das aufnehmen auf Tape und dann musstest
du es von Tape zum Videoschneiden natürlich wieder auf die Festplatte zurückspielen.
Das war ein Akt von Tagen bis das funktioniert hat. Aber du konntest halt ohne einboosen Capture.
War halt schon für die damalige Zeit sehr cool. Ja und rückwirkend aufnehmen war natürlich
auch nicht damals. Tja, das waren wilde Zeiten. Mit Dextory war es dann besser. Das habe ich
auch noch relativ intensiv verwendet dann. Weiß nicht ob es das immer noch gibt. 2007
letzte Version. Dextory. Die Webseite geht noch nicht mal mehr. Was ist das? Black Ops
3? Oder was bin ich hier sehend? Leute was ist das? Black Ops 3? Black Ops 2? Black
Ops 2. Wie das ausgeschaut hat man. Leute wir können wirklich froh sein, dass OBS am
Start ist. Ich habe damals, als ich noch mit meiner Black Magic Karte die Xbox gecaptured
habe, ich habe damals eine eigene Capture Software, also eine Minimal Capture Software
programmiert, die über Direct Show, war das glaube ich, von der Black Magic die Videos
abgegriffen hat und lossless encoded hat. Aus dem Grund, weil die Black Magic Karte damals
mega nice war, aber die Aufnahmesoftware nicht gut. Das war nicht lang, das waren irgendwie
100 Zeilen oder so. Das war wirklich super rudimentär. Also da können wir wirklich
froh sein, dass wir heute OBS haben und ich meine es ist ja nicht nur Elgato, Elgato ist
zwar das bekannteste, aber auch ordentliche Capture Hardware haben, auch teilweise wirklich
Dinge, wo du vor ein paar Jahren noch tausende für bezahlt hast. Mit 120 Herzsupporten. Also
muss man echt sagen, da sind wir wirklich blessed mittlerweile, was das angeht. Das
funktioniert heute einfach. Prager. Und OBS, wer das nicht weiß, die meisten hier wissen
es wahrscheinlich. OBS ist komplett Open Source Software, den man sich angucken kann
auf Github. Es ist eine, es ist Qt, Qt und es ist C++, ich glaube es ist eine C++ Qt
Software. Wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche. Glaube ich. Ja, ja, ist es. Ja. C++, OBS
Studio ist auch ein Riesending. Streamlabs OBS, was ist denn daraus eigentlich geworden?
Die haben sich ja nicht mehr OBS genannt, die nennen sich jetzt einfach Streamlabs.
Warum sollte ich Streamlabs versus OBS verwenden? Sehe ich nicht ein. Ich verwende das Original
OBS. Beste. Original OBS. So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt mal an? Battlefield Campaign.
Oh, nee, please, please. Die waren alle nicht gut. Die beste Battlefield Kampagne war Bad
Company 1. Dest konntest du eigentlich vergessen. BF3 finde ich ging auch noch, wenn man nicht
gerade irgendwie ein bisschen außerhalb der Map gelaufen ist. Okay, komm wir lassen uns,
wir skippen, wir skippen, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level Capture baiten. Lasst uns eine
Runde Level Capture baiten. Kredo, danke schön für den Sub. Hast du Protato schon gesehen?
Ist das ein Browser oder was ist das? Nee. Protato. Protato. Gunray, danke schön für
den Sub. Das sieht vom Artstyle übelst nach, wisst ihr was mich zu nennen sieht übelst
aus? Also die Monster sehen übelst nach Binding of Isaac aus. Findet ihr nicht auch? Ist das
vielleicht sogar vom gleichen Hersteller? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Nee, ist es nicht. Nee,
es ist nicht. Vom Artstyle her, ja. Nee, sagt mir nichts. Okay, lass uns mal Level Capture
baiten. Ja, bringt nichts. Die können noch so viel machen, das ist der Zurichsabgefahrene.
Ja, das ist der Zurichsabgefahrene, das ist der Zurichsabgefahrene, das ist der Zurichsabgefahrene.
Okay, das hier ist der Clip, den sie eins zu eins von World of Tanks geklaut haben oder
wie war das? War das nicht? Oder war das World of Warships?
...
Ja!
also es ist schon sehr auffällig oder wie ähnlich sich die spots sind
so game ist still set to launch later this year it seems like a new playtest is about to go live
battlefield one is currently seeing a major resurgence at the moment thanks to an eighty eight
percent discount on steam the player count has peaked at over 30,000 in the last 24 hours on
steam alone this massively dwarfs 2042 4000 concurrent peak player count though it'll
be interesting to see moment moment zeigt mal her
übrigens wisst ihr was aktuell relativ viele spieler hat ihr werdet es sich glauben new world
guckt mal hier also für für new world verhältnisse viele 123.000 aber das liegt nicht daran dass das
game jetzt irgendwie super super krass ganz neu ist sondern es gab wohl einen relativ großen neuen
content patch und es gab neue server wo die leute wieder von anfang an starten können und
frische server sind quasi immer ein guter gute möglichkeit für mmo spieler wieder zurück zu
kriegen overwatch 2 ne, overwatch 2 nicht auf steam kannst du nicht gucken
2042 numbers climb once the new season of content is out featuring the long-awaited class rebalance
cloud imperium game showed off the new updated cargo system coming to star citizen in the 3.18
patch cargo will be physicalized exist in the universe and lock all star citizen geht mir
sonst wo vorbei when ships are destroyed some of that cargo will be destroyed as well but it'll
also be salvageable from the whole of that cargo ship and possibly just floating around in space
as well this may open up new opportunities for piracy in star citizen but it is just the first phase
of really a full new cargo system it doesn't appear that the first implementation wollen die
nicht vielleicht mal irgendwie das game fertig machen anstatt 30.000 neue systeme einzubauen
okay fertig ist bei dem game ein dehnbarer begriff will include the manual unloading and loading of
cargo ships yet the new system is also coming with the new ui for buying selling and loading
goods onto your ship this upgrade and more will be hitting star citizen with the highly
anticipated 3.18 persistent entity streaming patch which we still don't really have a live
release date for the developers at treyark announced on twitter that modern warfare 2
will be making its ranked debut sometime in 2023 this will be ranked for vanguard in cold war
league play will begin to wind down this month and players will have until november 22nd to claim
any rewards in both games the devs are promising a new range of things with modern warfare 2 ranked
mode also ehrlich gesagt ich habe es jetzt die letzten tage wieder ein bisschen gespielt und das
einzige was ich wirklich in dem game spielen kann ohne durchzudrehen ist search and destroy
kreste halt ich nicht aus its rank playlists and rewards new skill divisions skill ratings
and a leaderboard many players online have pressed for a reduction in the severity of modern warfare
to skill based matchmaking in casual play perhaps infinity ward and treyark will loosen the
restrictions on sbmm and restrict it to the ranked modes no other details have been shared as a break
now in ranked soll es habe ich es richtig verstanden in rank gibt es weniger sbmm jetzt
sollte rank nicht der sinn von sbmm sein und public eben ohne sbmm oder ich habe es bestimmt
falsch verstanden aber man weiß da ja nie das week ea announced that they plan to release a major
ip sometime before the end of march next year sbmm nur in rank das glaube ich nicht die werden
sbmm nicht abschaffen aus quick play die werden es im leben nicht rausnehmen nur die anderen games
haben auch sbmm uns hatten leak und rank play this major title will be respawns upcoming star wars
jedi survivor the highly anticipated sequel to 2019 fall in order interestingly ea mentioned how
their marketing tactics would change in the future instead of building up excitement over a few
months they'll only market their games within the launch window they claim they're doing this
because of how well apex legends was received after it was announced just 48 hours before it
launched this method of shocking players with a surprise announcement and then launching the game
immediately seemed to affect player numbers positively this could explain why the marketing
has yet to start for the this kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen weil dann ist der hype am kurs und die
leute können gleich gleich ausprobieren star wars sequel ea may be holding off until we're closer
to the march launch window industry insider jeff grubb previously stated that survivor would be
nur dass mich halt ehrlich gesagt star wars nicht wirklich juckt aber okay ich glaube das letzte
das letzte star wars single player soll gar nicht übel gewesen sein
that is the major ip ea is referring to hell let loose is an extremely hardcore world war two
fps game that's amassed a significant following on pc and more recently console
the game's final update for the year is just around the corner and this week the devs shared
another sneak peek at the new content flamethrowers are being introduced to the front lines and will
make short work of infantry in close quarter combat the devs have stated that the flamethrower
will set enemy players ablaze and the surrounding area it can fire for about 20 seconds before
refueling is required different flamethrower variants will be available to the allies and
access forces alongside the flamethrower molotovs are also being added in the next update a single
direct hit on an enemy will incinerate them and burn the ground around them the winter update is
also adding new vehicles as well the willys jeep kubelwagen and gaz 67 will make traversing the new
snowy karkov map much easier this map is based on the flamethrower and the flamethrower will be
on the german invasion of russia it features ruined buildings open fields street lines and new winter
based factions an exact release date for the winter has been announced but the content will be
playable on the game's test client sometime next week in other ea news executives have signed a deal
with marvel to publish at least all resident sleeper marvel zeusch telling their own original story
within the marvel universe the first project being developed at ea motive is the iron man game
announced in september this is currently in pre-production and is being led by the
former producer of the guardians of the galaxy and avengers games uncharted's amy hennig is also
working with the new sky dance new media studio on their own marvel game this game is rumored to
feature black panther and captain america it's still being determined as the third ea marvel game
will be in august the embracer group the swedish gaming conglomerate bought square annex studio
for 300 million dollars this included studios like crystal dynamic
das ist ja soll das irgendein 2d tomb raider sein oder
itos montreal und sieht aber richtig billig aus annex montreal combined these studios have
published hits like deus ex thief and tomb raider just two months after this acquisition embracer
group is shutting down square annex montreal this studio had just rebranded itself to anima
focusing on mobile gaming in a statement in mobile game verstehe ah ja dann ist klar
the closure by saying that they want to focus more on triple a games from now on mobile game
sources online suggest that staff are being moved to itos montreal to work on a new game
activision blizzard ist disabling another hero in overwatch 2 a few weeks ago the bastion
da läufts bei den heroes were disabled due to bugs that made them i mean hey wenigstens disablen die
heroes und nicht so wie beispielsweise dass es in unverwundbarkeits glitch in mw2 gibt aber keiner
disabled das schild und vielleicht ist mittlerweile gepatcht aber es hat ewig gedauert wenn da
according to a tweet sent out by blizzard a bug with maze ice wall ability allowed her to reach
unintended locations on the map this gave the hero an unfair advantage over others some players see
this as a another skill the master when playing is made but it looks as if blizzard disagrees
there's no eta for when the hero will be added to the game this is yet blizzard disagree zu einer
menge was spieler sagen overwatch 2 but hopefully things will be resolved sooner rather than later
xbox boss phil spencer has once again assured gamers that microsoft will keep the call of duty
franchise auf der playstation ja das habe ich auch gelesen ist aber auch logisch das sage ich auch
schon die ganze zeit es macht überhaupt keinen sinn für die call of duty wirklich exklusiv für
die xbox zu machen das würde ja nur sinn machen wenn die verkäufe was es an geld zu holen gibt auf
der playstation in irgendeiner art und weise quasi auf der anderen seite das übertreffen
können also sprich könntest du mit einer exklusivität die in irgendeiner art und weise
vorteile verschaffen oder mehr geld verschaffen die das aufwiegen die verkäufe die du auf der
playstation verlierst und das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen das sind millionen was die machen an
geld mit playstation verkäufen das müssten die anderweitigen erst mal rein bekommen also und
selbst wenn es nicht direkt rein bekommen sondern quasi dadurch andere services pushen können dass
ich das unterm strich lohnt kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen console to ship on cod would ship
on it this topic has been at the very center of the microsoft acquisition discussion for months
sony is understandably concerned that cod may become platform exclusive which would impact their
sales as it stands microsoft will ship cod on playstation for several more years but things
still need to be clarified on what that means exactly it is interesting however that sony is
fighting hard to retain non-exclusivity despite having so many exclusive deals with cod modern
warfare 2 on playstation for example awards players with extra tier skips for the battle
pass an exclusive operator and additional loadout slots remedy announced this week that their
next major game launch is scheduled for next year alan wake 2 is the long-awaited sequel to the
cult classic which we're told is still in active development but progressing well remedy is also
working on codename condor which is a spinoff of 2019's control control blue fans away with its
incredible graphics and a mind-bending storyline ich bin riesen fern von remedy games ja also ich
habe auch alle was ich was heißt ich habe alle gespielt remedy hat nicht viele games gemacht
ja max payne 1 gemacht max payne 2 gemacht alan wake gemacht wie heißt das andere dieses time
traveling quantum break gemacht was haben die sonst noch gemacht war es das nicht schon wir
haben nicht viele games gemacht und jetzt halt control und ich muss sagen control war das erste
game was ich nicht gespielt habe ist die devs answer to that however it's still in a proof of
concept stage and a long ways off from release though according to the devs the prototype gameplay
already feels very fun another control game is also in the works at remedy codename heron
is suspected to be a direct sequel also kontrol war das erste was ich nicht fertig gespielt
habs game and continues the main storyline amd has just announced their new graphics cards the
radion rx 7900 xtx and the 7900 xt will take on the latest 4000 series from nvidia while specific
details and performance numbers were not shared during the press event some important points
were mentioned amd's cards will massively undercut the 4000 series the 7900 xt retailing
for 900 in the 70s solltest du auf die nächste ps 5 pro warten ist sie schon angekündigt es
wäre ziemlich bescheuert wieder eine pro rauszubringen halte davon gar nichts bei der
letzten konsolen generation ging es halt einfach nicht anders es war damals schon eine blöde idee
weil die sm so schwach gelanscht von der hardware das ist ja diese konsolen generation nicht das
einzige spiel wofür sich eine ps 5 aus meiner sicht lohnen würde also für mich zum spielen
wäre das aktuelle god of war modular design featuring a 5 nanometer gpu dai and a 6 nanometer
memory cache dai this makes the cards much more power-efficient compared to nvidia's offering
tech outlets like linus tech tips replicated amd's benchmarks which included data blazingly fast
show the new gpus relative performance targets they concluded that the 7900 xtx could offer
roughly 90 percent of the rtx 4090 performance but we'll have to wait for real-world data to
confirm anything rumors online suggest the japanese video game giant sega is gearing up to ship yet
another mini version of a classic console the packaging ja was anderes kriegen sie aktuell nicht
wirklich auf die reihe guckt euch mal das neues sonic an machen sogar hardcore sonic fern sich
drüber lustig mega mini drive 2 in japan contains a link to a customer survey the survey consists
of 47 questions one of which asked the customers what mini console they'd love to see from sega
next the options include classic hardware like the dreamcast game gear or another mega drive mini
sega has previously stated that the production on the mini dreamcast would be costly but would look
into it if the demand were there not only are these mini console remakes costly das kannst du
heute schon wahrscheinlich um was bei da wobei ob du weiß ich nicht nostalgic game aber auch
letztendlich introducing younger generations to classic titles gerade gerade sega genesis das war
ja gar nicht so schlecht von der hardware das war ja glaube ich das was so zu gamecube zeiten
irgendwie rausgekommen ist oder two streets of rage and castlevania before we move on to the last
topic of today's video let us know in the comments what you want from ridgeline games and their new
narrative driven moment moment ne ne genesis war ist der mega drive genesis ist ich glaube ich
habe es durch an der gebracht ne ne ne genesis dreamcast meinte ich der dreamcast war das
zu gamecube zeiten genesis ist das soll garantiert um das proje pi machbar sein das war ja das war
quasi der super nintendo von sega wenn du so bist oder sind sie nur interessiert in die multiplayer
mode gar nicht die developers die tech demo für sims leute wir haben es geschafft das ist
die technische power ea's next sims game it promises to build on the previous games and even
endlich eine simsteck demo jawoll detail customization unfortunately despite the game not being formally
announced it has already been hacked and pirated the hackers have stated that the new game will
run on unreal engine 5 and focus much more on online play ea has yet to make official comments
wie das aussieht es sieht aus wie so ein komischer küchen bilder im ikea im ikea stehen doch auch so
komische dinger rum wurde dir deine wohnung einrichten kann sie fast genauso aus comments
betten ohne scheiß heute pass mal auf wetten hier gibt es microtransaction options so nach dem motto
ja du kannst ein sim kann entweder zwei monate arbeiten gehen für neuen tisch oder du kannst
jetzt rein cashen und den neuen tisch direkt hinstellen das ist garantiert das garantiert
wieder übelst verseucht mit irgendwelchen payment und shops ich habe außer dem ersten
sims nie in den sims gespielt das erste sims fand ich damals von der vom ansatz her wirklich
erfrischend ja danach nie wieder reingeguckt in den sims best pc cases of twenty twenty two
schauen wir mal was sind die was sind die besten cases haben die other time stamps irgendwie so
dass man ja da unten steht doch da unten steht doch best budget best mit rate best mit range
best mit range case
wie kein fractal design ach hier best thermals da das kommt man zum an
was sind denn was ist denn best so also die beste beste airflow oder oder
bei den sims gibt es dlcs die zusammen über 1000 euro sind die sind nicht mehr ganz dicht
die spinnen komplett kein best pc cases muss ich mal kurz reingucken weil das das steht
das will ich mir vielleicht für den nächsten rechner holen 100 was wie viel das hat auch
gestern 240 gekostet ich habe danach geguckt 190 bei uns kostet 240 euro
warst du da neu mit wasserkühlung wahrscheinlich schon ja
die hardware preise sind alles andere als gesunken es ist teuer als fach sich neuen rechner
zu kaufen also ich rechne damit dass ich wahrscheinlich über 4000 euro ausgeben muss
wo würde man dort überhaupt wo würde wo würde man da überhaupt den radiator reinsetzen
da oben oder wie
vorne aber vorne ist der airflow doch dann wieder kacke
all the while offering a look that differs the torrent from the pack of now common mesh front
pounds 140 millimeter fans also wichtig ist dass das ding hat das ding in staubfilter
so sind staubfilter hier also wenn es kein staubfilter hat ohne staubfilter kommt
da nix hier radiator radiator an die front
weiß nicht
ist das aber dann ist doch der airflow wieder nicht man hat ein radiator oben und unten
staubfilter sind schlecht für den airflow ja kann sein aber das ist gut dass ich nicht
sauber machen muss
ok also das case ist anscheinend nicht verkehrt ich muss mal schauen immer noch unschlüssig
was es denn um ende wird was ist immer abkacken oder von monka es was ist hier los einfach
mal 1500 stream frame drops jetzt geht's wieder voter phone hat zugeschlagen
ne jetzt geht's wieder ok was können wir uns angucken huge fiber upgrade wiring my house
mit 100 gigabit ok wetten das ist ein ami haus und das erste was er macht ist eine säge
holen und löcher in die wand schrauben löcher in die wand sägen nicht schrauben ja wo ist
das hallo youtube vorschau ist wieder pepega ja er hat einfach löcher in die wand gesägt
wieder mal das kannst du halt in ami haus machen hier wird es ein bisschen schwierig
wann baut er denn überhaupt was der ist die ganze zeit doch nur am sitzen und allem erzählen
wo wo wo wo tut sich denn da was ah jetzt nee auch nicht hier ja das sind irgendwelche
boxen die sie in die wand gesägt haben wieder weil es irgendwelche ami holzwände sind
was ja ja das ist typisches ami haus wieder das bringt das bringt gar nichts das ist halt
nicht praktikabel für uns hier auch wieder die komischen unify krempel am start was
in der sinde unten von drei geräte und irgendwie acht schalter und vor allem wozu naja gut
das ist natürlich ein toller test für gigabit für 100 gigabit mal den speedtest zu machen
mit 271 mbit über wlan das ist natürlich ganz besonders außerall kräftig ok sinnlose
video
ich habe 100 gigabit netzwerk aber was mache ich einen speedtest über wlan alles klar
6 hat so muss man das ausprobieren so nicht anders dass die holzwand überhaupt den schrank
hält ja nee das war doch ein reck was auf dem boden stand ane du meinst ein netzwerkschrank
ja tatsächlich wer weiß er ist bestimmt konzern
das ist wirklich eines der wenigen spiele wo ich mich seit
jahren jetzt darauf freue aber ich kann es halt nicht spielen weil ps5 und ich sehe es
nicht ein ps5 zu kaufen gottes abbild dankeschön für den sub aber bringt halt nichts weil
ich will keine ps5 kaufen nur für ein game was ist das mit eurem konsultantas verdient
es haben sie es endlich geschafft nice nur irgendwie eineinhalb jahre oder zwei jahre
nach view 3 release super das wollten sie übrigens glaube ich schon anfangen des jahres
releasing dieses meisterwerk hat nur eine schwäche lasst mich raten dass es irgendwann
mal vorbei ist ich hoffe die games das spoiler nicht normalerweise geben sie sich immer verhältnismäßig
ja ja nee eigentlich ja sie sagen immer es ist spoiler frei aber irgendwie doch doch
oft nicht also insofern
also wir können uns entweder das angucken oder wir gucken uns das games da video an
wir gucken uns das games da video an hoffen dass sie nicht spoilern fand es ok hab schon
angeschaut ok also wird nicht gespoiler alles klar
guck guck gleich gleich schon der erste spoiler das das ist die die dings ja aus dem aus dem
extra von dem typ der man am ende gekillt hat als nach 30 stunden der abspann des neuen
god of war läuft müssen wir erstmal tief durchatmen denn das was santa monica studio
da abgeliefert hat ist eins muss man ja auch den wirklich zu gut halten ich glaube es
gab noch kein wirklich schlechtes god of war von der main serie ja über den mobile ableger
und dann ist das remake davon auf der ps 4 oder was kann man sich vielleicht streiten
aber insgesamt die main god of war titel waren alle richtig gut wenn man so games mag aber
eigentlich ist das auch sehr zugänglich also eigentlich kann es kann es jeder mögen
für dieses testvideo ist das action feuerwerk aber für eine ziemliche heraus ich spoiler
weil was ich spoiler ist das letzte game was vier jahre alt ist also wer das jetzt
noch nicht gespielt hat und sich jetzt ein review zum darf also ich weiß nicht umgestellt
denn die zweite reise von kratos und adreus durch die nordische mythenwelt ist so voll
gepackt mit coolen überraschungen dass es wirklich schade wäre wenn wir euch die verderben
würden ich bin so neugierd durchaus fähig deshalb haben ich bin so neugierd durchaus
fähig das und ich dazu entschlossen dieses testvideo maximal spoiler frei zu haben so
muss es sein hier nur das nötigste damit ihr all diese selbst erleben könnt ich hoffe
ihr habt dafür verständnis und seid gleichzeitig so fair anderen auch nichts zu spoilern bleibt
denn da die überraschung nur um eine sache kommen wir nicht herum ihr solltet sowohl
für dieses video als auch fürs eigentliche spiel das god of war von 2018 durchgespielt
haben zwar gibt es in ragnarok zu beginn eine kleine zusammenfassung die enthält aber wirklich
nur das nötigste mein so viel passiert ist jetzt ja eigentlich wenn man mal so die story
zusammenfassen will so viel passiert ist ja eigentlich im letzten god of war gar nicht
ja kratos ist jetzt irgendwie in skandinavien und hat einen sohn und die mutter ist gestorben
und sie wollen jetzt die asche auf den berg bringen und dann kommt am anfang irgendetwas
fremder zu ihm ins haus und dann kloppen sie sich und dann machen sie sich auf den weg
die asche zu verstreuen und dabei bringen sie ein paar götter um und am ende sie kriegen
geholfen von von freja und frejas sohn ist der böse und der endgegner im ersten teil
der wird dann gekillt und dann ist sie sauer und am ende kommt raus dass treos quasi loki
ist und kratos der vater von loki so das ist das ist die story von god of war 2018 auch
eine menge von dem aus was für ein verständnis das war es eigentlich ist doch in den test
in dem ihr nicht nur erfahrt warum es ragnarok in die wertungssphären eines meisterwerks
geschafft hat und welcher kritikpunkt am vorgänger auf epischer weise eliminiert wurde sondern
auch warum der trip durch den bitter kalten finnbuhlwinter eine altlast des ersten vatersohnabenteuers
wieder mit sich bringt dieses video wird euch präsentiert was jetzt ein unfall alter die
und das ist eine gute frage ich bin gar nicht mehr sicher was die eigentlich gegen kratos
überhaupt haben gute frage nächste frage
so viele göter bringt man glaube ich gar nicht um im letzt in god of war 2018 oder so
man bringt irgendwie einen sohn von tor bringt man glaube ich um bald nur bringt man um diese
komische schlange hilft einem ja weil weil sie die göttere auch nicht ab kann ich glaube
das war es ich glaube das glaube das war sogar egal wir gucken jetzt das wird fertig uns
aber stehen geblieben klag dein versicherungs manager also meiner ist es nett also ja und
das ist dieser allwissende typ den man im ersten tag weiß gar nicht mehr warum man den sich
geholt hat dieses mürrische gesicht würde ich überall erkennen ist das nicht der typ
denn die zukunft keine ahnung ich weiß nicht mehr genau darf ich fragen was genau passiert
ist drei jahre sind seit der reise von kratos und atreus auf den höchsten gipfel jötenheims
vergangen dort hatte das duo die asche von kratos übrigens hat er nicht am ende vom
letzten god of war sogar seine wie heißt das diese diese ketten weggeworfen und dieses
game hat er sie wieder ok über die riesen lande verteilt seitdem hält der fimbulwinter
mit gart mit seinen schneemassen fest im eisigen griff und dann wäre da natürlich auch noch
ragnarök das große nordische göttas sterben das ende aller tage das einer prophezeiung
nach auch den tot von kratos bedeutet doch während die ausgangslage für vater und sohn
zugegeben düsterer kaum sein könnte kratos ist ja am ende von god of war drei schon gestorben
und war dann wieder am start weiß ich wurde das überhaupt jemals erklärt warum warum
kratos god of war drei überlebt hat glaub nicht weil das ende von god of war drei ist
ja kratos bringt zeus um und ersticht sich dann selbst so und warum lebt er eigentlich
wieder ok auswurscht er lebt und sterblich ganz parkade und explodiert die geschichte
von god of war ragnarök ist sie ein großer segen denn jetzt geht es ans eingemachte und
zwar in allen neuen welten der nordischen mythologie ja die dürfen wir diesmal nämlich
alle bereisen es geht in der story um schicksalhafte entscheidungen und die zu erleben ist speziell
im letzten spiel drittel das wirklich vollgepackt mit nix f ja keine fremdrops nix f magischen
momenten ist ein riesengroßer genuss der soundtrack soll aber ziemlich gut sein
von der reinen inszenierung der spannenden mythensage und der charakter tiefe vieler
nebenfiguren und antagonisten ist ragnarök ein absolutes meisterwerk eines das wir übrigens
wahlweise mit einer hervorragenden deutschen oder englischen ich habe was gehört das ist
mein sohn was in jones meidas namen ist mit ihm passiert ist jetzt viel zu groß und sieht
jetzt so aus ist deine schuld und noch besser kommt mit einem orchestralen soundtrack daher
der uns gleich mehrfach die gänsehaut auf den armen also der soundtrack war immer wirklich
gut das muss man sagen alle god of wars hatten super soundtracks kann man sich unter unabhängig
vom game heute noch geben
an der story zu kitteln haben wir aber leider auch denn wie bereits der vorgänger leidet
auch ragnarök spielte mit deutscher oder englischer also ich würde auf jeden fall auf englisch
spielen teil an deutlich spürbaren problemen mit dem pacing und verstrickt sich immer wieder
in nebenschauplätze die uns aus der spannenden handlung reißen wahrscheinlich muss es das
game weil ansonsten zehn minuten wäre es in zehn stunden durch anstatt 40 oder so ragnarök
in teilen unnötig gestreckt was unter anderem an häufigen backtracking passagen liegt gerade
ab der mitte des spiels sehr unschön auffallen hier auch eine kleine empfehlung für euch
verlässt die recht linearen hauptpfade der geschichte für kleine und normale schatztruhen
nicht allzu häufig sie ziehen das spiel in die länge und bringen oft nur ressourcen die
e im überfluss vorhanden sind erst recht wenn ihr euch mit nebenaufgaben die zeit vertreibt
zu denen kommen wir aber später noch ist halt die frage ob man nicht mein belohnung
bei neben seit tracking ist halt dass das das eine so aber man man sieht halt auch was
von der spielwelt was ja ein großer teil von so games mittlerweile ist wobei ich gelesen
habe dass das neue god of war kein open world game im klassischen sinne ist sondern quasi
eher mehrere große areale hat was ich ja persönlich gut finde weil es muss nicht alles open world
sein um open world zu sein einfach nur mal nicht ganz so stark ins gewichtfeld liegt
in erster linie an den durchweg fantastisch geschriebenen dialogen kratos atreus und andere
figuren haben immer was zu erzählen und es macht einfach spaß den teil zu morphe teils
von leid erfüllten dialogen zu lauschen richtig klasse ist auch dass selbst kleine anspielungen
und hinweise aus teil 1 in god of war ragnarok wortwörtlich große spuren hinterlassen haben
falls sich übrigens sorgen um den technischen zustand macht können wir für beide plattformen
entwarnung geben god of war ragnarok erscheint zum release in einem fertigen zustand und
lässt uns auf der ps5 die wahl zwischen fünf grafikmodi die uns ein spielerlebnis in sechst
sekunde sekunde was was haben wir hier 30 fps oder 60 fps und dafür gut die auflösung
reicht ja was hfr was zum teufel ist hfr ist das hdr ist das ist das hdr nur anders geschrieben
oder was ist high high rendering was ist hfr und was ist verr ach da unten steht ja da
unten steht high frame rate variable refresh rate ok na dann tja ich habe eine ps4 ich könnte
es theoretisch auf der normalen ps4 spielen aber 1080p 30 fps und wahrscheinlich schlechtere
grafik ich weiß ja nicht dann warte ich lieber bis es auf den pc kommt und ich spiele auf
den pc jetzt wenn ich mir schon so ein teuer neuen pc kaufe sich fps bescheren auch das
haptische feedback und die funktionen des duessens wurden beispielsweise bei gratis
axe-wurf sinnvoll eingebunden und lassen uns die wuchtigen kämpfe noch mehr spüren von
wachs wurden wir übrigens nahezu komplett verschont um wenige neu starten wir zwar
wobei so viel später kam das oder god of war pc release wann kam das auf dem pc raus
2018 nicht das ist später ihr könnt es nun endlich auf dem pc spielen 2000 ok wirklich
drei jahre später keck letztes jahr im januar irgendwie anfangen letzten jahr ok das kann
wirklich drei jahre nach dem pc na gut da war noch ein bisschen die waren dank der fair
platzierten rücksetzpunkte aber nicht weiter wild kollege chris hat sich für euch außerdem
die ps4 version angeschaut und ist auch hier voll des lobes auf der alten hardware sind
zwar nur 30 fps möglich die hält ragnarök aber auch in den hektischen kämpfen stabil
dabei weiß auch die bildqualität zu überzeugen die nahe an der ps5 ist was die ps5 optik
anbelangt ihr seht es ja selbst optisch ist ragnarök von gratis detaillierte rüstung
bis zum tollen art design der spielwelten und gegner ein überaus hübsches spiel dass
wir hier einen cross gen titel haben merkt man im spiel nur ganz selten an klar die gesichtsanimation
sind nicht auf höchstem ps5 niveau eines der last of us part 1 und ladezeiten werden
bei solchen quetschlich durch die felsen passagen auch kaschiert aber hey hier meckern
wir gut auf ganz hohem niveau apropos muss es laden wie wir es bereits aus aktuellen
playstation exklusiv spielen wie horizon forbidden west und the last of us part 1 kennen findet
ihr direkt im hauptmenü eine vorbildliche auswahl an barriere bekommt man eigentlich
mittlerweile eine ps5 das god of war bundle heißt jetzt übertreibt halt mal übertreibt
halt mal
das ist schon ganz schön teuer oder aber gut ich mein zu machen aber es gibt ja auch
keine games warum sollte ich mir eine ps5 kaufen es gibt es gibt keinen sinn ist wenn
es gibt ein spiel was ich dafür spielen würde es gibt ja da habe ja weniger spieler als
auf der switch dann freiheitsoptionen von farbfiltern über bewegungshilfen bis hin
zu rätselunterstützung und hochkontrast anzeigen ihr könnt hier eine riesige menge
mehr anpassen doch weg von der story weg von den hilfen kommen wir zu dem hier oh ja
dem unfassbar wuchtigen kampfsystem hier übrigens zuallererst die ganz wichtige info für fans
der frühen god of war spiele die im vorgänger die vielzahl an epischen bosskämpfen vermisst
haben die anzahl wurde deutlich erhöht und was ihr hier seht ist noch einer der unspektakulärsten
mützel die übrigens manchmal auch ganz schön fördern können generell wurde von blitze
spuckenden echsen bis hin zum zentaurer ähnlichen pirscher deutlich an der gegnervielfalt geschraubt
und es scheint das hätte gratos bereits im vorgänger jeden troll aus den neuen welten
verjagt okay ganz korrekt ist es nicht einem troll sind wir dann doch begegnet aber formulieren
wir so game director erik williams und sein team haben sich den kritikpunkt offensichtlich
zu herzen genommen und bei uns mehr gegnervielfalt gesorgt doch nicht nur an diesem punkt wurde
gefällt insgesamt sind die kämpfe über das spiel hinweg eine ganze spur abwechslungsreicher
auf wunsch taktischer und auch dank brutaler finisher eine ganze ecke blutiger
beim thema abwechslung sind in ragnarök gibt es zwei weitere varianten der sparten rage mit
der wir unter anderem gratos gesundheit regenerieren wir haben neue schilde gefunden mit denen wir
besser parieren eine menge schaden ablocken oder sie für einen angriff aufladen können sicher
ist euch auch aufgefallen dass unser liebster spartaner jetzt weit agiler ist und sich
beispielsweise mit seinen chaos macht immer daily scrub jetzt an markierten stellen hoch
zieht und von plattformen auf feinde herab springt auch allerhand neue kampffähigkeiten
kann unser liebster wüterig erlernen welche attacken zur wahl stehen ist dabei erneut an
das jeweilige level der waffen gekoppelt die wir in der zwergenschmiede von brock und sind
die mitgefundenen ressourcen aufwerten einzig dass uns ragnarök ist noch peter agil auf
link in ihr erfahrungspunkten allein durch das spiel der story belohnt und sie gegen ende des
spiels obsolet macht hätte besser gelöst und für mehr motivation sorgen können ob mit der
ax oder den chaos klingen das kampfsystem aus god of war ragnarök muss sich hinter keinem
action spiel verstecken einen nicht unwichtigen anteil daran hat aber auch atreus der drei jahre
und zahlreiche kämpfe später zur überaus hilfreichen unterstützung im kampf gereift ist
der gute teilt schaden aus sondern schickt auch imposante zauber aufs schlachtfeld hier
eine kleine wie bereits im vorgänger wird boi hat ja mal eine zeit lang auf twitch gestreamt
weiß nicht ob der noch aktiv der hat fortnight gestreamt auf twitch aber nicht nur gekämpft
sondern auch gerätselt auf die cleveren knobeleien treffen in regelmäßigen abständen im verlauf der
geschichte wo wir beispielsweise zum öffnen eines durchgangs wasserfronten in korrekter
reinfolge mit gratosachs einfrieren müssen ich glaube ich habs wenn man den geysir einfriert
die mit rätsel haben es ebenfalls wieder ins spiel geschafft geben uns erneut idunäpfel zur
steigerung der gesundheit oder blut meht hörner zur steigerung der sparte coole leute coole
leute machen die kiste halb rückwärts und nur mit einem arm auf so ja natürlich so macht man
immer kisten auf exakt so macht man nur kisten auf wenn hier die kamera ist dass die kamera
reingucken kann und nicht durch gratos durchklitscht aber gut hey ist es denn gelb mit hörner zur
steigerung der sparten reich aber es sieht stylisch aus doch nicht nur das kampfsystem
wurde ordentlich aufgepumpt generell ist god of war ragnarök in sachen umfang ein wahrer
riese und das liegt nicht nur an der überaus ordentlichen spielzeit der geschichte erstmals
können wir von der feurigen hölle muspelheim über die farbenfrohe zwergenwelt zwartalfheim
bis nach asgard alle neun welten mit abstrichen erkunden mit abstrichen da nicht alle reiche mit
großen offenen hubs versehen sind in niffelheim finden wir beispielsweise lediglich eine kampf
arena in der wir ohne schaden zu erleiden unsere attakten üben können und diesen wunderschönen
rabenbaum hier odins späher sind erneut in den welten zu finden und warten darauf dass wir sie
mit der ax vom himmel holen am rabenbaum winkt dann stufen unterteilt eine überaus wertvolle
belohnung für gratos wie schon im vorgänger sammelt ihr im verlauf des abenteuers wieder
verschiedene rüstungen dir genau wie die waffen auch bei sind und rock verbessern könnt
sehr gut an dieser stelle übrigens eine coole info für alle die bei gratos viel wert auf
was für ein monitor hast du eigentlich 21 zu 9 16 zu 9 und auch nur 1080p mit dem neuen rechner
wenn ich den dann einmal habe gibt es wahrscheinlich ein display endlich gibt es ein transmog system wer
will kann sich aber locker flockig weit über 50 stunden mit dem action adventure die zeit
vertreiben dabei besondere ausrüstung einsammeln und durchaus auch abseits der hauptpfade spaß
haben da hätten wir interessante nebenmissionen in denen wir beispielsweise mehr über mimias
düstere vergangenheit erfahren und auch zahlreiche fordernde challenges die den walküren kämpfen
ähneln und in denen wir unser erlerntes können im kampf auf die probe stellen allerdings sind nicht
alle missionen ihre zeit wert bei so manchen banditen lagern oder der ein oder anderen töte
x-monster-mission und wir wieder daran erinnert dass ragnarök nicht nur während der story doch
etwas zu stark aufgeblasen wurde aber weil das alles rein optional ist drücken wir hier gern mal
ein auge zu erst recht wenn sich unter den nebenaufgaben auch allerhand lohnende perlen
verstecken das gefühl in god of war ragnarök von aufgaben überflutet zu werden hatten wir
hingegen nie einige bereiche der open hubs werden im stil eines metroidvania erst durch ein neues
gadget freigeschaltet und auch so manche truhe bleibt ohne den nötigen zauber über viele stunden
hinweg verschlossen so was finde ich eigentlich immer ganz gut da musste dann im hinterkopf haben
da habe ich noch was vergessen das macht dann wenn man backtracking muss das irgendwie ein
bisschen spannender ja je nachdem wie man gucken ich also ganz im ernst ich würde es wirklich gerne
spielen aber ich will mir keine ps5 für ein game kaufen da lohnt es sich im späteren verlauf des
spiels ja ich könnte auf der ps4 spielen aber ich habe eine ps4 nicht pro also das weiß ich nicht
ob ich mir das geben kann zurückzukehren denn wer weiß welche geschichte oder welch packender boss
kampf hinter der zuvor unüberwindbaren klippe lauert hat er boi eine neue stimme nee ich glaube
da ist einfach auch real life ein bisschen älter geworden da lauert wirklich so einiges ps now
cloud gaming so blöd ist die idee glaube ich gar nicht moment ps now pc was war ich glaube
so doof ist die idee gar nicht kann ich playstation plus hier erfährst du wie du playstation plus
erfährst du wie du playstation plus spiele auf dein pc streams das game ist nicht drinne ne die
wollen damit konsolen verkaufen oder
ne ne das kannst du vergessen
will be on ps plus
no gut das heißt ich kann es nicht auf dem pc spielen ich muss mir eine konsole kaufen
na geil nee da kaufe ich mir keine konsole ausmacht klingt also sehr vertraut deshalb können wir durchaus verstehen wenn da in den
kommentarspalten das ist doch nur god of war 1.5 gespottet wird googles wie ein boomer ich bin ein boomer
und außerdem wie sieht das bitteschön aus was wie zeichnet sich google googling aus von 2018 wählt mit
ragnarök nicht durch die inzwischen 17 jahre alte action serie da war alles neu kratos hatte sich
von einer anderen seite gezeigt die interaktion des vaters sonen gespanns gab so noch nie und
gameplay und setting holen sich deutlich von den früheren abenteuern des spartaner ab es ist
richtig dass ich die ersten spielstunden von ragnarök sehr vertraut anfühlen aber lasst
euch davon nicht täuschen denn während das bekannt großartige kampfsystem und die welterkundung euch
von anfang an reinziehen hat ragnarök noch eine menge überraschungen in der hinterhand trotz aller
länge mittel teil und dem gelegentlichen backtracking gelingt es dem spiel nämlich
seine spannende story zu einem epischen ende zu führen und dabei gleich mehrere kritikpunkte
aus dann das ist bestimmt torr oder so so ein dicker typ 1 aus der hammer mit mit hammer nicht
mehr ein verdammt gutes gott und blitze sondern ein musterbeispiel dafür wie die fortsetzung zu
einem absoluten action meilenstein auszusehen hat ja ohne konsole ist da nix ich
würde es gerne spielen aber ich will mir einfach keine ps5 kaufen ich werde ich werde die konsole
nicht verwenden leute ich habe mir die xbox 1 damals gekauft und ps4 das war der größte
fehlkauf überhaupt ich habe beides quasi nicht benutzt da habe ich ja schon mehr die switch
benutzen die habe ich auch kaum benutzt also jetzt eine ps5 für nur ein game ich weiß nicht
nene können wir das level cap video anschauen und das ist doch bestimmt wieder nur krasses
debate oder es ist doch wieder typischer level cap schwach sind oder wann das einer doch mit
dem anderen überhaupt nichts zu tun bettel viel wisst ihr was das einzige ist was bettel viel
gekillt hat das ist bettel viel selbst weil sie den kack game released haben qualität setzt
sich durch und es hat das game einfach nicht gehabt
ich werde mich nicht dazu äußern wo ich meine ausbildung gemacht habe beziehungsweise wo ich
gerade bin wäre blöd warum sollte ich jetzt warum sollte ich da zehn jahre aufpassen dass
ich nicht zu viel über mich liege und der jetzt irgendwie großartig was erzählen
also wie gesagt ich würde es gern spielen aber keine chance also ps5 wird nicht gekauft soll
was haben wir sonst noch hier feier schipp video
uni statt groß kann das gehalt als jurorprofessor fürs lehren und forschen lohnt sich das das
gucken wir jetzt i built a massive cat wall for my cats and raccoon sind das mehr schweinchen
nee waschbären sind das waschbären waschbären das muss ich mir jetzt angucken
alter ist das daily dose auf internet das hört sich original an
hey everyone hallo everyone das ist da ne ne ne doch nicht aber aber ähnlich aber ähnlich
we have a really long ähnlich ähnlich hallway in our house so we decided to partner up with
catastrophic creations in order to turn this wall into a cat wall so ordinarily this hallway
would be a great waste of space but by converting it to a place for the cats es ist im prinzip
einfach nur überdimensionaler kratzbaum oder wie naja gut was soll es auch sonst sein und
warum sie kratzbäume immer original mit diesen sind immer die gleichen teile das sind immer
so holzdinger mit mit strikt rumgewickelt zum kratzen könnte man noch irgendwie mal
ein bisschen ein bisschen anders die sein jeder kratzbaum sieht so aus
also chico wäre das egal wenn ich sowas hinstellen würde die wird sich das angucken
sagt ich kletter doch da jetzt nicht rauf
warum ist seine wand magnetisch an manchen stellen das auch wieder so ein ami ding
schrauben warum kann der man knete einfach an die wand machen
ach weil da in der mitte irgendwelche metall halterungen für die wand sind oder wie ok ok
jetzt hat er sich das metall rausgesucht und er bohrt dort direkt wo das metal ist ich
check es gerade nicht die arme schraube jetzt wissen wir auch wozu man eine grafikkarte
braucht mit wasserwaage dass wenn die man nicht mehr aktuell ist dass man sowas damit
verwenden kann es das bessere wäre wahrscheinlich nicht so ultra auf drehzahl drauf zu drücken
aber gut es hält es hält das ist das wichtige
ok so spannend mir zuzugucken wie es an die wand schraubt ist es auch nicht oh das tut
ja weh beim zuhören schon ok jetzt gibt es eben so eine hängematte
bekommt ihr auch teilweise auf youtube irgendwelche handwerk irgendwelche
tool und handwerks tipp shorts angezeigt von irgendwelchen indern die ganz ganz furchtbar
abstruses zeug machen und das hat dann irgendwie 30 millionen views so letztens habe ich den
so einen short empfohlen bekommen der hat glas innen innen loch also da hat ein loch
gebohrt und hat glas in das in das loch gefüllt hat dann irgendwie gesagt jetzt damit hält
das viel besser totaler totaler blödsinn oder irgendeiner der der der wollte irgendwie
den rohr verlängern und hat festgestellt dass sein verlängerungsrohr nicht reinpasst
und dann hat er das rohr irgendwie breiter gemacht mit irgend so einem ja weiß ich was
das ist in so einem bohrer aufsatz und danach war das rohr irgendwie schon halb ausgefranst
wo ich mir gesagt habe was zum teufel sehe bin ich da sehend wieder
das tut weh
so und jetzt mein noch ist das nur ein recht großer kratzbaum und ich werde ich gläber
ich kann ich muss mal kurz vorspulen das wiederum könnte ich mir vorstellen dass das
schicko gefallen würde so eine so eine hängebrücke
das ist der begrenzer ach das ist dass das quasi nicht nicht fester nicht zu fest dreht
oder so das macht meiner auch aber da macht andere
geräusche also wenn ich bei mir den drehmoment einstelle
na doch das macht auch so ähnliche geräusche ja
tatsächlich na doch
doch dass der der der kopf springt
tatsächlich sehr egal dass hier ist hält und gut ist es hört sich aber irgendwie ungesund
ich muss uns jetzt nicht komplett angucken ich will eigentlich nur wissen hier jetzt
jetzt darf die kanz drauf
also schicko wird sich erstmal nicht trauen aber ich glaube so eine hängebrücke würde
der gefallen so hängebrücke durch wohnzimmer oder so das fände ich schon geil
also ich sage euch was meine machen würde ist folgendes die wird auf die brücke laufen
und sich jetzt erstmal in die mitte legen für eine stunde und da ein bisschen hängen
ein bisschen abhängen
also ganz trau zu dem ding noch nicht hier ne das ist mir nix oh das ist auch ganz schöner
ganz schöner chonker hier unten oder da sind die so ordentlich die denkt sich oh ne ich
soll da jetzt hoch klettern monka es klettern ich bin zu dick zum klettern die nicht die
unten und die dahinten denkt sich welche low iq aktion laufen denn da wieder im flur
denn
das muss reichen das muss reichen genug bewegung genug bewegung
die hüpft gleich wieder runter oder wird jetzt die muss die brücke erst mal verteidigt werden
die ist nicht dick die hat einfach nur viel fett glaube aber die andere sieht ein bisschen zu dick
aus aber kannst es auch so wenn die älter werden die neigen dazu ein bisschen dicker zu werden also
meine ist jetzt auch nicht super fett aber die dünste ist auch nicht aber noch im rahmen guck
ist alles ok das kann schon mal passieren
was das ist jetzt der waschbär ok der waschbär ist ungefähr genauso dick wie die katze
wie viel haben die denn ein hund drei katzen und zwei waschbären da ist aber was los da hast du
keine ruhe halber zoo ja echt so
so der knabbert jetzt erst mal da irgendwie die liege durch
diese kak youtube musik ja das ist so nur so nur nach 15
ok der finns geil dem geht einer ab drauf
das ist noch gar nicht fertig ich dachte schon alles fertig gebaut geht noch weiter dauert
drei tage aufzubauen jetzt kommt high IQ installation hier wird diagonal skaliert
da wird mich auslachen wenn ich zu der sache hüpft da mal rüber weil wo soll die hin dann
hier wieder runter oder wie da wird mich zicko aus damit sich was hast du sie noch
alle da gehe ich doch nicht drauf im leben wird er zicko nicht draufgehen
ist einfach nicht gleich aufgebaut komplett na gut wahrscheinlich weil die fiecher gedacht
haben ey was geht da im flur ich muss da mal drauf das auch gleich begutachtet ist das
verletzungsrisiko nicht hoch nee was soll man sich da verletzen großartig man ist ja
nicht doof weil katzen können klettern ja und waschbären auch der hund nicht aber ansonsten
was soll man sich da groß und selbst wenn die katz von da oben runter fällt der passiert
ja nichts verletzungsrisiko vielleicht für ihn wenn er sich dann kopf dran anhaut moment
das ist noch mal eine andere katz oder die haben vier die haben vier katzen die haben
die vom anf die haben die anf die haben diese graue vom anfang die haben die weiße die haben
die schwarz weiße und die haben die schwarze vier katzen ein hund zwei waschbären also
katzen haben kaum fall damage korrekt
oder ist das die gleiche vom anfangen ich erkenne es jetzt nicht genau es kommt immer
ein bisschen aufs licht an immer noch nicht fertig denn da bist ja wirklich eine woche
beschäftigt
also ich glaube chico wird sich das ding einmal angucken und nie verwenden die ist so
faul was das angeht oh guck mal die decke hat es auch geschafft
nee ich glaub nee das andere katz guck die hat weiße foten und ist so ich glaube das
sind wirklich andere
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass um diese brücke hier ab und zu mal ein bisschen gerangel entsteht
dass denn der waschbär da drauf liegt die katz schmeißt ihn runter oder umgedreht oder
die kats schmeißen sich untereinander da gibt es dann gibt es da gibt stress ja ok
erstmal den bobs putzen alles klar die katze aus meins gehst du weg ok also im prinzip
war das jetzt einfach in 14 minuten sponsoring für dieses ding hier ja das war sehr anstrengend
alles
ich habe hunger leute pippo fettheim jetzt können wir uns noch angucken was kurzes angucken
wollen wir uns noch den uni professor angucken was verdient man was verdient man als juraprofessor
vom 11 minuten das geht noch ich hoffe die haben keine monka tostmusik da drin ich etwas
nicht als juristen bitte im beruf pissig sein und im leben fröhlicher mensch gute erklärung
als juristen bitte im beruf pissig sein und im leben fröhlicher mensch mein vater hat
mir mal früher einen floh ins orgel gesetzt dass anwälte viel geld verdienen und wenig
arbeiten würden und dicke autos fahren würden das wollte auch mein name ist martin mattis
ich bin 46 jahre alt universitätsprofessor in augsburg im fachbereich jura dann starte
ich mal den tag wie eigentlich jeden tag geht der tag erst mal zum frühstück schon mal
anzug anhaben so muss das sein mit quark und blau werden wie so jeden morgen geht es
dann mit dem frühstück ist das ein drucke geht es dann nee oder was was ist das jeder
neben das ist kein drucke oder was ist denn das ein grill ok sieht aus wie tintenstrahl
tross und multifunktionsdruck wie so jeden morgen geht es dann mit dem frühstück an
den rechner heute ist vorlesungstag das bedeutet wir müssen um 10 uhr die erste veranstaltung
halten das muss ich mir anschauen ein stream deck was ich jetzt die nächsten anderthalb
stunden mein studierende machen werde als professor ja das kann man sich eine stunde
vorher mal angucken was man erzählt finde ich auch mal alles gefühlt erst mal lehren
da für die studierenden das heißt man versucht ihnen alles an wissen zu vermitteln was sie
für die juristischen staats examiner brauchen und man hat einen zweiten teil der eben mit
der professoren tätigkeit verbunden ist dass die forschung also lehren und forschung gehen
hand in hand soll noch ungefähr gleiches gewicht eigentlich ausmachen und das heißt
man untersucht halt rechtliche probleme wettet sie auch gut dann oh hier bin ich dann stelle
ich auf die uhr stelle fest es ist schon recht spät ein paar löffelchen noch und dann flitzt
mal los aber gutes gutes monitor setup auf dem set wir fahren ist ein gefühl von schweben
und freiheit für die kurze strecke wir haben ungefähr vier kilometer mit dem auto macht
keinen sehn mit dem auto zu fahren es ist wie immer man hat ich sag mal segway segway gibt
es das überhaupt noch ist das warte mal was segway nicht die dinger wo der gründer aus
versehen mit segway die klippe runtergefahren ist und irgendwie danach wollte nie jemand
segways kaufen also heute haben wir alle elektroroller total cool ist das denn gucken
wir mal hier denken was das für ein spinner das kann man definitiv im gesicht sehen ja
gut man könnte sich einfach elektroroller heutzutage holen aber so lange man so ein
teil noch hat der fährt einfach in der uni darum easy direkt ins büro gefahren 25 minuten
die vollendungs beginn gucken wir mal nach wir brauchen noch die folien die wir vorbereitet
haben na hellen sieht ja auch nicht gut aus zur anzug das geht ja nicht mein vater hat
mir mal früher ein flow ins orgel gesetzt dass anwälte viel geld verdienen und wenig
arbeiten würden und dicke autos fahren würden und diesem ehrglauben war ich als kind erlegen
und wollte doch dem jubel studieren der weg des universitätsprofessor war dann tatsächlich
über die phase der promotion wo ich dann lehren durfte und da muss man sagen habe
ich blut geleckt das hat mir so viel freude bereit und die resonanzen das feedback war
so überwältigend gut das musste ich weiter machen da war ich ein stück weit süchtig
nach wenn man das mal so lagen darf heute haben wir etwas lehrer sein ist wirklich
eines der schlimmsten sachen ich mir vorstellen kann aber an der uni geht es vielleicht ich
weiß nicht aber gerade an einer normalen schule stelle ich mir unglaublich ätzend vor allein
schon die ganzen asi kinder und die asi eltern schwierige abstraktere materie leider vor
die ist nicht ganz so lebendig kann man nicht ganz so schön edutäment machen eine information
mit einer emotion koppelt wird man sich ewigkeiten daran erinnern und wenn ich jetzt eben blöden
witz reichen die edutämen die studierenden lachen haben seine emotionen die verbinden
dann diese informationen mit der emotion dann bleibt die getriggert ich denke mann ich hab
alles dabei also immer sprüche machen kleinen hörsaal und da gehen wir jetzt gleich rein
die ersten ein zwei termine ist etwas mehr nervös weil man eben noch nicht weiß wie
wird die veranstaltung ankommen wie ist die gruppe dort heute haben wir für diese veranstaltung
den zweiten termin das heißt also auch noch relativ junge dozenten zuhörerschaft beziehung
das heißt da müssen wir noch gucken so die lehrer hallo hallo darf ich schon übernehmen
dann schalte mal die technik hier ein beide bima nicht so viel los alter diese räume sehen
teilweise echt immer aus wie als wären sie na gut ich wollte gerade sagen wie vor 100
jahren gebaut aber wahrscheinlich sind sie auch vor hundert jahren gebaut sind es immer
so so nackische räume einen schönen guten tag ich darf sie ganz herzlich zu unserem
zweiten termin begrüßen wir haben im ersten termin so ein bisschen die einleitung gemacht
zu der veranstaltung heißt warum gibt es diese veranstaltung in welchen bereichen hat
sich das entwickelt antidiskriminierungsrecht 55 stunden pro woche nicht schlecht dass ich
jetzt endlich sie ordentlich diskriminieren möchte es ist folgendes meine information
mit einer emotion koppelt wird man sich ewigkeiten daran erinnern ich werfe hierher auf den tisch
das prallt ab und trifft sie dann das heißt ich ziele auf ein anderes merkmal als ein
solches was eins nach dem agg ist aber die wirkung wird sie genauso treffen weil der
zusammenhang zwischen ihnen und dem merkmal der typ denkt sich jetzt alter lass mich in
ruhe kannst du das nicht mit irgendjemand anderem demonstrieren muss ich das jetzt
echt sein der wird sich das nicht merken so stark ist dass es die betrifft machen wir
einen einfachen fall den sie auch schon hatten ich möchte jemanden einstellen der tatsächlich
nur formel namentags arbeitet statistisch gesehen wird die kinder erziehung in deutschland
überwiegend von damen wahrgenommen statistisch rein und aufgrund dessen können die frauen
dann schlechter weil sie am nachmittag niemanden hatte die kinder betreut vorsicht über die
tita ab oder ähnliches wenn dann benachteiligt das heißt das merkmal nachmittags tätigkeit
ist eigentlich geschlechtsneutral habe den merkmal geschlecht nicht zu tun durch den
statistischen zusammenhang wird aber eine mittelbare benachteiligung von damen daraus
bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit nächste woche bleiben sie gesund
das sagt er doch jetzt nur weil er weiß es wird aufgezeichnet oder was soll er sagen
er kann auch schlecht sagen alter ich kann mein professor überhaupt nicht ab wobei ich
könnte mir ohne scheiß jetzt mal unabhängig davon was soll er anders sagen ja aber ich
glaube der also ganz ehrlich der vortrag wirkte auf mich als ist tatsächlich spannend zuzuhören
ja und als lernt man da auch was ich glaube nicht dass es schlecht ist aber davon absehen
was soll er anderes sagen er schafft es auch diese systematischen themen uns auch mit humor
bei zum bringen zum beispiel jetzt auch mit den beispiel hier mal mich vor abgeworfen
hat ist eine einfache aber auch zielbringende darstellung hat ja eigentlich wie immer spaß
gemacht also immer schön jetzt aber da siehst du was das ist jemand der hört sich selbst
gerne reden und du musst auch jemand sein dass du so was machen kannst wenn du wenn
du selbst da kein bock drauf hast dann dann wird das nix schnell zur büro zurück und
dann gehen wir kurz zum unikum was essen das ist für die alternative zu mensa muss
ich selber schon irgendwie cool finden und gerne reden hören anders anders kannst du
was glaube ich nicht machen und sonst das wirken auch nicht überzeugen also die sind
immer super billig dabei mit mit essen ich muss allein schon zehn euro am tag ausgeben
in frankfurt 75 euro monatlich man ist ja nix also wenn ich in frankfurt essen gehen
würde können ich locker am tag zehn euro ausgeben nur für essen mache ich ja nicht
also ich nehme ja meistens mittlerweile sogar was mit weil es mit zu teuer ist hat mir ja
hier auch eine motivation zwanzig gebaut ist von war mit der maßart gibt es eine figur
die heisst bahn der stinzen der hat sich damals eine motivation wird gebaut mit ganz
schönen schönen sprüchen gut jeder was ihm gefällt so und dann ist man auch schon motiviert
und gut gelaunt ich dachte erst hier auf den ersten blick das wäre das mw2 cover ist es
aber nicht es kommt wahrscheinlich noch raus dass es lenz armstrong ja jetzt haben wir
ungefähr noch eine dreiviertel stunde wir werden im bgbt sein und dann werden wir so
ein bisschen die grundlagen auch anfangen semesters legen und wenn erklären was sind
sachen was sind rechte wie kann man die zuordnen wie stehen die sachen zueinander das kann schon
mal sein passiert aber sehr sehr sehr sehr selten dass die technik der einen im stich
lässt und das wird man sich die frage warum gammeln die eigentlich da vorne rum und sitzen
da nicht hinten man gerade selber unfähig oder liegt an der technik sind das die schleimer
die früher auch tasche getragen haben oder ich glaube heutzutage muss keiner mehr dem
professor helfen die technik anzuschließen oder also bei uns in der schule war ja video
und generell technik immer ach so das sind gar keine studenten es funktioniert tatsächlich
etwas nicht das ist dann schon mal so der eine wie man geht nicht an beide wie man
gehen nicht anders ist irritierend haben wir noch zwei minuten in der hoffnung dass wir
das fixen können wie sie sehen sehen sie nichts das ist ja da würde ich auch ein bisschen
nervös werden strom ist nicht an hat mir noch irgendjemand den strom abgedreht in hoffnung
dass da jetzt was kommt gut aus der wollte den trollen der typ davor wahrscheinlich da
hat gesagt auch bevor ich raus geschalte ich dem einfach noch mal den strom ab
schönen guten tag ich darf die ganz herzlich dankeschön für den zapp der weg war steinig
universitätsprofessionen gibt es eben sehr sehr wenige wenige stellen viele leute dieses
gerne erreichen wollen weil man ja ein paar vorteil auch damit hat ins bunde natürlich
verbeamtet ist dass man forschung und lehrer betreiben darf und das hat eben auch ein stückweite
ein gewisses renommee in der gesellschaft und deshalb möchten dass viele machen das
heißt ist man weiß ist leute der hat tatsächlich was gearbeitet von morgens bis bis jetzt mittags
was ist da los nicht ob der hat gearbeitet hat gegessen hat gearbeitet da gibt es tatsächlich
leute die arbeit noch was marcario danke für den zapp die tragen wird wir sehen uns hoffentlich
übermorgen in alter frische wieder bleiben sie gesund sagte mal warum klatschen eigentlich
alle außer studenten die klopfen auf den tisch die erste tages hilfe ist die drum um 17
uhr die erste tages hilfe rum klick komisch aber ja das ist der lehrteile jetzt vorbei
ist jetzt darf ich mich an den forschungsteil tradition sich ab nach hause weil das so gemacht
wird ja ich weiß aber warum wenn das mal mit der segway rumgedüßt ja die plebs klatschen
die die hrq leute klopfen amter hat man eine private krankenversicherung wie man abziehen
muss das sind dann also nach abzug der krankenkasse ungefähr 44 zufrieden mit dem gehalt ich
habe alles oder geht schon was was ich brauche und brauche nicht mehr das ist das eine was
man sagen kann wenn ich aber bedenke was ich bereits als berufs einsteiger vielleicht hätte
verdienen können ohne doktor titel und ohne habe litigation das heißt mit neun jahren ausbildung
weniger hätte ich einen einstiegs galt gehabt angebote gab von duschelhofer ganz lein von
120.000 euro brutto im jahr da hätte aber auch nicht das machen können worauf er bock hat also
wahrscheinlich ist doch schon wie eine gute kombination jetzt kommt daneben auch der
forschungsteil und ja das steht jetzt erst mal als nächstes erst mal prioritär an
doch der arbeit die mit ihm wir dürfen nicht vergessen es sind auch 55 stunden die woche
habe ich ganz vergessen es sind 55 stunden die woche dann ist das dann relativiert sich das schon
wieder mitarbeiter eingereicht hat zu lesen korrigieren anstatt 40 stunden zu betreuen
es bleibt nicht so viel in der freizeit sage ich ganz ehrlich also mir ist es natürlich wichtig
dass ich zu familie und freunden kontakt halte weil das ist natürlich 55 stunden die woche
das sind das sind elf stunden am tag oder weiß ich ob die samstag sauber machen keine ahnung
es ist aber schon ordentlich ja 55 ist wirklich heftig tatsächlich täglich mit meinem vater
ansonsten reise ich gerne ich fotografiere wahnsinnig gerne bleibt eigentlich nicht viel
zeit dafür außer während des reisens überall aber wisst ihr was auch sein kann dass das übers
jahr übers jahr gar nicht gar nicht so viel mehr ist weil die haben bestimmt doch auch pausen und
ferien und und da wo eine uni nichts läuft oder das ist doch das ist doch wahrscheinlich
umgerechnet so dass es im schnitt wieder halbwegs normal ist da vorne die schönsten bilder meiner
reisen irgendwo auf die wand gehauen oder ausgedruckt oder so ich wohne hier in augsburg
weil es nicht weit von der uni weg ist hier kommen knapp irgendwas kilometer kann man
segway gut fahren hat mir da er mag sein segway auf jeden fall zugelegt was ist hier klein 86
oder mit der ist nicht klein und da habe ich mich einfach ausgebreitet fühle mich heimisch und wohl
das war es von meiner seite ich hoffe ihr habt ein bisschen spaß interessantes video zumindest
zumindest habe ich bei ihm wirklich das gefühl gehabt der mag seinen job da finde das toll
natürlich finde er sich selbst toll und hört sich selbst gerne reden aber das musst du in
der position auch anders geht das gar nicht und ich kann euch noch empfehlen hier seht ihr auf
der seite noch ein paar informationen zu recht haben als fachangestellten und hier noch weitere
videos das heißt schaut rein format gefällt mir ganz gut vielleicht euch ja auch weiterhin
nice finde ich immer ganz interessant
triple monitor elgato stream deck ja so muss das sein
ich trage euch
so haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes eigentlich habe ich richtig kollab mittlerweile aber ich
warte noch kommen halbe stunde oder so kurz nach zwölf wo ich was zu essen online vorlesung
einfach auf twitch streamen und auf sattr hoffen wo werden denn online vorlesungen gestreamt haben
die da haben die da eigene portale bei der uni oder gibt es auch leute das einfach auf youtube
oder twitch streamen weil was geheimes ist es ja nicht zoom ich meine die bessere bildqualität
hätte twitch und youtube auf jeden fall als teams youtube und twitch ist qualitativ auf jeden fall
besser als zum oder teams man ist ja nichts geheimes theoretisch könnte man das war einfach
public stream auf twitch warum nicht skype um das sehen zu dürfen warum eigentlich warum
eigentlich ich meine wo ist das problem wenn es jeder sehen darf
stimmt ja gut wenn du das publikum stream ist das was anderes aber du musst ja nicht das publikum
stream so vortrag an stream ja ein paar fragen ist tatsächlich schwieriger oder stimmt schon ja
ok dass das verschließt leuchtet mehr klingt plausibel saman was haben wir sonst noch
ne das kommt jetzt nicht feier schipp video nimm in 100 sekunden ok komm feier schipp feier
schipp ist immer poc general purpose systems programming lang nimm a general purpose systems
programming language that can deliver die einzige general purpose system programming language dies
geben darf ist rast weil nur rast ist blazing fast high performance native apps with concise elegant
code it was created by andreas rumpf in germany in 2005 who wanted a language with the performance of
c the productivity of python and the extensibility of lisp systems languages nimm is statically typed
and compiled however it's unique because its source code is first translated to a different
language usually c then uses a compiler like clang to convert it to machine code and it can also
transpile to c++ objective c and even javascript by default it uses a deterministic memory
management strategy based on reference counting but this behavior can be customized or removed
altogether allowing low-level control over memory with pointers syntactically it feels
like a statically typed python but it also provides ok die syntax sieht schon einmal halbwegs
brauchbar aus extensive support for metaprogramming with a macro system that allows direct access to
the abstract syntax tree allowing you to mold the language to your exact needs much like the
list family of languages to get started install it on your machine then create a new file ending
in dot nimm unlike c no main function is necessary use echo to print to the standard output or create
a variable with the bar keyword and follow it with an optional type annotation but we can
make them single assignment with let or use cons to make the assigned value immutable when
writing a complex statement like an if condition indentation matters like python this keeps the
code nice and readable like when declaring multiple variables for loops it has a variety
of built-in i weiss es ein beispiel ja ich weiß ich weiß das ist ein beispiel aber man
hätte einfach auch schreiben können c gleich b oder oder c gleich not b hätte man sich
das sparen können aber ok das ist ja wie gesagt beisammen das weiß er ja auch built-in iterators
like count up and count down or you can use the iterator keyword along with yield to build your own from scratch to define functions or methods we use procedures which can take input arguments and return a value it also supports proxies and using procedures as arguments or return values for functional programming patterns however it's also possible to use object-oriented patterns by first creating a complex type which can then be instantiated like a class and it also supports generics allowing you to use types as parameters okay
die generics syntax ist schon wieder komisch im really special though is it support for meta programming for example we can get the abstract syntax tree at any time using dump tree ok das ist das ist lisp gedürnt jetzt we can now write our own macros which are like functions that modify the abstract syntax tree at compile time it's like
ok das ist das ist jetzt eben was für lisp quets was heißt ist immer blöde frage wenn ich nim einfach nach c transpilen kann dann könnte ich theoretischen microcontroller mit nim programmieren ist halt die frage ob du in nim c header importieren kannst und so was dass du das aufrufen
kannst du mehr short videos like this thanks for watching and i will see you in zwei ist aber keine sprache die mich großartig interessiert ich muss sagen dass von den ganzen sprachen die so in letzter zeit ein bisschen ein bisschen hype hatten muss ich sagen dass ich relativ interessant finde aber auch nicht interessant genug dass ich damit großartig was machen würde
ich finde ich finde die idee dahinter ganz gut die sagen c plus plus sagt wir brauchen was besseres und nach dem motto aber ansonsten ja gut es gibt ja immer noch karbon von google wobei ich glaube nicht dass ich das durchsetzen wird war da bumm
bums da bumm 27 monate dankeschön massiv subscription dankeschön für den sub ansonsten ich glaube wir sind auf ewigkeiten stuck für microcontroller und für unreal engine mit c plus plus für immer wir werden das nie wenn das nie los werden und mit jeder sprach iteration wird es wilder und planloser
hast du heute schon über das twitter drama geredet gibt es da was neues also was das letzte was ich mitbekommen habe ist dass es den abo button nicht den abo button schwachsinnig abo button geckl
dass es das häkchen jetzt zu kaufen geben soll und dass ilon irgendwie 50 prozent der leute entlassen hat und dass ganz viele leute jetzt geflüchtet sind schon von twitter so nach dem motto oh nein das geht ja hier nicht und dann frage ich mich halt wohin wollen sie denn flüchten es gibt ja nichts vergleichbares zu twitter also ja da habe ich vorhin schon was drüber gesagt ansonsten
was da da ist doch niemand zu nitter das ist doch keine alternative da ist doch keiner
also ich bin gespannt wie sich das entwickelt ich sehe keinen grund für mich jetzt erstmal twitter nicht zu verwenden
mal gucken was da noch kommt ganz ehrlich wenn es total abkackt wird es irgendeine sinnige alternative zu geben und es wird wahrscheinlich nicht mastadon oder so sein sondern es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwas neues sein wo die leute dann drauf aufspringen
aber ich sehe jetzt auch noch nicht den großen untergang von twitter ehrlich gesagt
twitter darfst du machen eine neue bude auf ja sollen sie mal machen also mal abwarten mal abwarten ich bin gespannt wie sich das entwickelt ich persönlich mag twitter für mich ist also ich finde twitter ist das beste es ist ja kein richtiges social netzwerk was an mastadon so schlecht ist gar nichts gar nichts benutzt halt kaum einer
ich finde twitter ist immer noch das beste social netzwerk wenn man so nennen kann was ist die alternative denn facebook oder instagram tiktok rein für text messages und also ohne mist für so security news und schnell sachen mitbekommen was gerade passiert ist twitter das beste was es gibt
ja telegram da kannst du zum wendler in die kropo gehen ja aber telegram ist ja ein instant messenger eher weniger so ein public ich weiß du kannst gruppen machen und so also ich also ich mir fällt keine sinnvolle alternative aktuell ein zu twitter ja und selbst hacker news verlinkt öfters auf twitter
also insofern ich denke nicht dass twitter bald weg sein wird
in einem jahr schließen die also ich glaube nicht dass der wirklichen interesse daran hat twitter zu schließen in einem jahr so viel wie das gekostet hat zumal er das ja irgendwie glaube ich auch per kredit mitfinanziert hat ja geldtechnisch läuft twitter glaube ich noch nie gut ich glaube twitter hat noch nie gewinn gemacht
mal abwarten bin ich bin gespannt was da rauskommt
ja das finde ich auch richtig pepega ja das habe ich auch gelesen so nach dem motto jeder jeder darf sagen und machen was er will aber wenn einer sein werbevertrag auslaufen lässt dann soll er public geshamet werden und sowas das ist auch das ist ziemlich hängen geblieben
für 40 milliarden nicht millionen
milliarden millionen wäre ja noch kein ding das bezahlte nebenbei mal
also ich finde twitter gut mich ist twitter das beste social so netzwerk was es gibt was er dann twitter ein bisschen nervig ist ist dass da halt so viele selbst wie soll man sagen so so sich selbst bestätigende leute unterwegs sind ja also die quasi immer ganzen tag bestätigung brauchen dass sie gute menschen sind so und dann
die sich quasi untereinander die ganzen tag auf die schulter klopfen sozusagen ja ja so ist das gut so ist das richtig ja die anderen sind doof aber wir wir sind die wir sind die toll da ist twitter ganz groß drin so aus allen lagern machen das da viele gerne auf twitter
ja die millionen werden ihm vielleicht fast aus der tasche gefallen
das ist der dümmste tweet zum thema weiß ich ob ich das aufmachen soll
naja leute ich hab hunger ich glaube ich geh jetzt was essen es ist 12
massive people fat time
also leute wir sehen uns bis dann machts gut